[Musique]
Marc etchanger bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement Marc etchanger 62 ans
auteur j'ai écrit maintenant le 7e livre
être publié cette année et je fais des
livres d'investigation j'ai aussi fait
des romans qui sont des faux romans qui
collent en fait beaucoup à la réalité
qui sont des romans d'espionnage
et à côté de ça j'ai une activité qu'on
retrouve dans les romans qui est tout ce
qui est écrit dans les romans colle à la
réalité et cette activité c'est du
renseignement sur des zones de guerre ou
sur des zones disons un peu compliqué
qui sont un peu chaudes voilà honorable
contributeur barbouse ou agent
moi je travaille
euh beaucoup sur tout ce qui est
corruption sur T les problématiques de
corruption à l'international sur les
gros problèmes de corruption pourquoi
parce que j'en ai beaucoup souffert
parce que j'ai perdu pas mal de gens
là-dedans
et je remarque que bah en France par
exemple la police antiorruption elle
elle a beaucoup de compétences c'est des
gens vraiment qui travaillent beaucoup
mais à l'international ils ont des
faiblesses il faut pouvoir leur donner
un petit soutien et c'est valable aussi
pour d'autres organismes et donc bah il
y a des financements qui sont dégagés
pour que des personnes comme moi
puissent aller sur des zones aller
chercher des documents et on en parlera
ce soiront dégagé par qui comment et
combien par des grosses fortunes
essentiellement comme je le vraiment le
le mode de financement le mode de
fonctionnement il est décrit dans un
roman qui s'appelle le réseau
euh le but du jeu c'est de de montrer
comment un agent qui est un ancien
légionnaire franco-sud-africain et une
agente du mossade euh travaille ensemble
pour récupérer euh
euh des données sur un laboratoire qui
fabrique une drogue de synthèse euh ils
vont faire des des aventures un peu
partout dans le monde mais les
personnages sont vrais les lieux sont
vrais j'ai tout respecté même la couleur
euh et le mode de fonctionnement du Réau
est vrai voilà la le financement grosse
fortune combien alors quand on parle de
grosse fortune c'est des gens qui ont
plus d'un milliard donc pour lesquels en
fait un financement d'opération ça peut
être une centaine de milliers d'euros
c'est dérisoire je veux dire c'est c'est
même pas la variation de leur
portefeuille dans la journée jeance de
club de bridge voilà c'est c'est bon
donc euh quand je rends des documents à
une autorité ça peut être un juge ça
peut être un commissaire de police ça
peut être ce genre d'autorité là ça peut
être le FBI récemment le FBI l'unité de
laav 433 en Israël quand je donne ces
documents-l je leur dis comment je suis
ils ont suivi la route ils savent
exactement comment ça s'est passé et
cetera il y a pas de secret à ce
niveau-là et donc ça me permet aussi
d'intervenir auprès de de de procureur
et de pouvoir leur donner quelque chose
qui soit exploitable il y a rien de pire
que d'aller voir un procureur en lui
disant bah voilà j'ai C j'ai des
documents c'est des documents qui sont
chauds qui sont probants mais je peux
pas vous dire comment je les ai eu parce
que là il peut pas c'est fini et donc le
le but du jeu c'est c'est de pouvoir
dire ben voilà la chaîne elle a été
suivie par telle ou telle
autorité avec ou sans leur accord peu
importe c'est toujours pareil on a des
feux rougge des feux oranges des feux
verts qui d'une autorité qui peut être
concernée parce que ça crée un dommage
quand récemment pour être clair autorité
française là c'est une autorité
française dans dans le dernier cas j'ai
sourcé des documents concernant la
corruption de Benjamin netaniaahou euh
avec la police jordanienne avec un
ancien de la CIA on a collecté ces
documents on les a montré à une
autorité
israélienne moi j'ai fait mon procès
verbal pour les autorités françaises
pour les autorités israéliennes et pour
le
FBI le les Américains et les israéliens
se sont retrouvés aux États-Unis à
Washington pour en discuter et un
procureur a été saisi du sujet un
procureur américain un procureur
américain c'était juste avant les
élections américaines donc le procureur
a regardé ça il a dit ok c'est très bien
il y a pas de problème avec le la
qualité de documents le sourcing il y a
pas de problème il y a qu'un problème
c'est que le pays est en guerre et nous
on va avoir les élections américaines
donc on met de côté ça veut pas dire on
met sous le tapis ça veut dire on met de
côté pour que ça puisse être réglé ou
jugé ou étudié moi ce que je demandais
c'est en fait j'apporte les documents ce
que je veux derrière c'est une enquête
je je juge pas je j'accuse pas je veux
simplement qu'il y a une enquête je dis
voilà moi j'ai ça ça me vient de là et
là on l'a eu comme ça et après moi je
veux une enquête c'est tout il il t'
posé la question qui vous a financé
pourquoi est-ce que ça peut être un tout
est clair à ce niveau-là tout est clair
à ce niveau-là bon avant de rentrer dans
le détail de ces petites
histoires de rentrer dans la
géopolitique dans le renseignement dans
l'acquisition de renseignement de
première main de première sources de de
première importance on va faire un petit
tour sur ce qui se passe en Europe sur
ce qui se passe en Afrique sur
voilàe lead un peu le Chad il faut
regarder en ce moment c'est très très
intéressant c'est intéressant mais et
c'est tellement douloureux mais mais ce
que je vous propose c'est de faire un
petit tour comme ça gé Mo qui propose
c'est moi qui propose et tu on verra si
tu disposes pas de souci avant avant de
commencer tout ça on va écluser les
blackagus pourries se faire choper dans
une base de sous-marin avec un uniforme
français une montre connectée quand on
est en charge de la dissuasion nucléaire
ça te fait penser à quoi à la croisière
s'amuse la Grande Vadrouille c'est une
erreur d'incompétence alors qu'on avait
déjà secoué la DGSE la DGSI qu'on
s'était foutu de leur gueule pendant des
années et des années c'est parce qu'ils
sont fait ils sont fait remonter
jusqu'en bas de leur bâtiment et puis en
plus par des journalistes alors
imagine-toi si c'était quelqu'un d'une
puissance étrangère cherchant à faire
des ingérences ça te fait penser à quoi
des mecs à l'île Longue qui se sont
chopés avec une monte connectée et qui
se font remontter c'est c'est sûr que
c'est dommageable
euh c'est ça fait amateur
euh on peut mettre ça sur le dos de la
lassitude on peut mettre ça sur le dos
de je te bienveillant non pas
bienveillant mais ça me rappelle ça me
rappelle les deux agents russes du GRU
qui sont allés tuer un de leur voilà
scripal et qui se sont fait ressourcer
par bellingcat et on a vu le leurs
photos je t'arrête tout de suite arrête
arrête là ici il y a que des Français on
on se compare pas au derniers de la
classe que Pierre Paul Jacques aille se
faire goer parce qu'ils ont is dans la
même chambre et que tu comprends qu'ils
ont été visiter une cathédrale et que
c'était des touristes on n a rien à
faire tu comprends ouais donc là on va
parler on est en France c'est notre pays
nos services c'est des branques ou c'est
pas des
branques ils sont pas dans les premiers
de la classe mais c'est une question
culturelle moi qui travaille avec
différentes nationalités le la base du
réseau avec lequel je travaille c'est
différentes nation nationalité je vois
les différences culturelles je vois
l'agressivité je vois l'absence totale
de barrières que peuvent avoir certains
cette absence totale de barrière la
France l'a pas c'est que nous on
travaille dans les règles on n'est pas
on n'est pas jusqu'au boutiste comme ça
il y a pas il y a pas ça et il y a pas
cette liberté il y a pas aussi ce ce
partage entre le côté public et privé un
ancien agent de la CIA qui sort de la
CIA il reste quand même attaché à sa
maison et la façon dont il travaille
avec sa maison et avec le FBI derrière
qui vérifie quand même que ça tourne pas
mal c'est c'est hyper
lâcheance non pas comme ça
[__] c'est c'est plus sa maison c'est
des liens mais mais ça n'a rien à
voir ça vient du recrutement ça vient de
quoi ça vient de la formation ça vient
du recrutement ça vient aussi du niveau
et aussi du salaire qui est payé c'est
pas les mêmes salaires non plus donc on
n pas forcément la même qualité de
personne et puis c'est pas les mêmes
budgets euh donc bon on fait qu'on peut
voilà tu peux pas niqueter français
oui c'est une question de budget bah oui
c'est une question de budget tout est
une question de budget une opération
elle se fait ou elle se fait pas en
fonction du budget et à un moment quand
vous on source des documents bah pour
que la personne les donne à un moment ce
que déteste faire les journalistes mais
à un moment faut peut-être payer il y a
un moment où il faut investir il y a un
moment où il faut pouvoir proposer
quelque chose en échange il y a moment
où il faut pouvoir exfiltrer et avoir la
personne pendant un certain temps
ailleurs et ça coûte on exfiltre bien
salé
oui ça c'est sûr ça c'est sûr pourquoi
ça te fait marrer parce que lui il avait
il avait son budget personnel mais bon
énorme mais mais voilà mais mais on est
passé si on regarde un peu le passé
français on
a le patron de la DGSE et le patron de
la DGSI qui ont tous les deux été mis en
examen et pas pour petit quand même il y
en a un je crois qu'il a eu une dizaine
de mises en examen à la DGSI l'autre à
la DGSE trois mises en examen l'affaire
tu par alors il y a Squarcini d'un côté
laffire à moitié jugé Bernard bagelet
c'est pas jugé tu parles de de ils ont
essayé de récupérer leur ce noire parce
qu'ils ont pensé qu'il s'était fait
enfler qui c'est pas c'est pas ça qui me
qui m'a qui m'a choqué ce qui m'a choqué
le plus avec cette histoire là c'est
c'est que ça arrive au moment où on est
en train de se battre en Syrie
ça arrive au moment où on est on a on a
fait le le désastre libyen et où on
commence le désastre syrien et que le
patron de la DGSE avec tout le respect
qu'on lui doit parce que c'est un
arabophone c'est un ambassadeur de
qualité c'est c'est il se mettre
là-dedans alors qu'il y a ça qui se
passe à côté mais on se dit mais mais
qu'est-ce qu'il fait il a rien que ça à
faire mais pendant une période on a eu
comme ça bah le un tandem avec les deux
patr des deux entités les plus
importantes en matière de renseignement
qui se sont retrouvé mises en examen
impossible ça à Londres on n jamais vu
ça entre le MI5 et le MI6 on n jamais vu
ça aux États-Unis on a vu des gens qui
avaient des difficultés à la CIA bon la
CIA c'est quand même particulier mais
mais le patron duéque du Sud oui B oui
Duan Claridge il a
pas il a pas c'est pas des cadis voilà
mais par exemple après quand il a pris
sa retraite bah c'était le patron de
l'honorable compagnie des Fighter qui
est un réseau aussi comme celui qui est
monté après c'est exactement la même
chose et il a fait des choses pour son
pays il a fait des choses avec le réseau
des anciens de la CIA qui était superbe
quand il y a eu par exemple la débacle
en Afghanistan en
21 en août 21 l'opération pinepple qui
consistait à exfiltrer
ouais ananas qui consistait à à
exfiltrer des Afghans euh bah ça a été
monté par des anciens et pas par des
gants qui étaient en
fonction bon revenons à à l'Europe à
notre dossier toi en tant que je
t'appelle barbous espion honorable
contributeur tout me va bien
P l'EUR ou la guerre avec les Russes la
guerre avec les
Ukrainiens qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là
c'est quoi ta lecture
alors moi j'ai pas je me suis tâé pour
voir s'il fallait avec les anciens
légionnaires voir s'il voulait aller en
Ukraine et cetera ça ça leur disait rien
mais j'ai commencé j'ai regardé un petit
peu quand même et il y a quelque chose
qui m'a beaucoup
choqué il y a un port ukrainien qui est
à côté d'Odessa de mirolay qui s'appelle
le port d'lvia le port d'lvia c'est le
port le plus dangereux du monde pourquoi
parce que à cet
endroit-là on charge les armes qui ont
arrosé tous les conflits de la de Cuba
les missiles venaient du portolvia tous
les conflits africains les armes
viennent de cet endroit-là c'est quoi ta
source ah bah ma source c'est le c'est
l'histoire du renseignement c'est c'est
c'est 50 ans de renseignement
et et ce port il est important pour les
Russes parce que ça leur permettait donc
d'amener les armes toujours en e libre
jusque en Afrique assez rapidement à peu
près en 10 jours 12 jours alors que si
leur retire le port d'Olvia ils ont plus
que Saint-Pétersbourg qui est pas en eau
libre tout le temps et donc ça leur pose
un problème de livraison quelques c'est
c'est 6 mois je crois de mémoire avant
que les les Russes nvahissent l'Ukraine
le
Qatar achète le port
d'Olvia et là les brasment tombe je me
dis qu'est-ce qu'ils viennent faire à
cet endroit-là à sur ce port
spécifiquement et donc j'ai cherché à
creuser je voulais y aller pour voir un
peu ce qui s'y
passait ça s'appelle maintenant que
terminal Qatar terminal c'est toujours
en fonction ça appartient toujours au
Qatar ça a pris un peu des coup mais pas
beaucoup ça a pas été vraiment
attaqué mais le Qatar possède
aujourd'hui ce port qui est
considéré du fait de son exportation
d'armes uniquement de l'exportation
d'armes comme étant un des ports les
plus dangereux du monde aujourd'hui il
raconent qu' envoient du grain bon je
veux bien mais ça reste quand même
quelque chose qui est angoissant j'ai
posé la question à des confrères en leur
demandant mais pourquoi euh notamment
israélien je leur ai demandé pourquoi
que vous savez pourquoi le Qatar a fait
ça personne m'a voulu dire mais par
contre on m'a dit si tu vas aller là-bas
ça va quand même être difficile tu vas
avoir des difficulté et donc voilà
et moi j'ai pas pu avais pas de raison
de travailler sur l'Ukraine aussi parce
que j'étais c'est pas mon mon terrain de
jeu habituel moi c'est l'Afrique et
Moyen-Orient
euh j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu pour aider
de temps en temps à droite à gauche mais
pas plus que ça en
revanche ce que je constate aujourd'hui
c'est que la partie du donbas qui est la
partie pour laquelle tout le monde se
bat aujourd'hui elle est archiminée pour
l'instant elle a il y a 5000es au m Carr
d'accord donc si demain on signe un
accord de paix et que Poutine prend le
Dombas il prend un tmine il prend une
région qui synthétiquement n'a plus de
valeur donc à mon avis quand ses
collègues vont voir que bon bah la
guerre s'arrête là ils vont faire le
bilan côté russe catastrophique
qu'est-ce qui récupère un territoire
inutilisable et est-ce que tu peux
penser contre toi-même sur cette phrase
là c'est-à-dire que il récupèent un
territoire inutilisable mais qu'il
veulent pas laisser aux autres
la question la question c'est pourquoi
ils ont tellement fait couler le sang
pour l'avoir que ils vont pas le laisser
aux autres et à la limite la partie du
donbas c'est des gens qui étaient
russophones on peut dire bon allez
culturellement c'est comme la Crimée la
Crimée a toujours été russe faut pas
c'est pour ça qu'on s'est pas battu pour
la Crimée la Crimée a toujours été russe
depuis la Grande Catherine
mais cette partie
donbas est-ce que ça valait la peine
de faire tuer autant de gens pour
récupérer un tas de de un territoire
entièrement
miné certainement pas tu t'es posé la
question
pourquoi c'est il y avait ils avaient
plus le choix ils étaient tombés dans un
engrenage où il fallait absolument
Poutine ne reste un SAR de Russie qu'à
condition que ça soit l'homme virile qui
gagne et il faut qu'il gagne or si la
guerre s'arrête on fait le bilan est-ce
qu'il aura gagné il aura gagné rien il
aura gagné un territoire où il y a
plutôt des gens assez âgé peu productif
et un territoire bourré de mine j'ouvre
une parenthèse quand tu te diriges sur
un conflit sur un pays sur une région h
quelle est ta pierre angulaire ta clé de
lecture ta clé de voûe ton prisme de
lecture quand tu débarques sur place ta
première couche deuxème couche 3è couche
sur le conflit ukrainien quelle est ta
première couche ta deuxième couche ta
trème couche d'abord il faut comprendre
l'histoire il faut comprendre pourquoi
ça peut avoir un intérêt il faut
comprendre que l'Ukraine c'est l'endroit
où il y a des plaines qui permettent
d'aller sur la Russie et que
historiquement l'Ukraine a été le
territoire par lequel on a toujours
envahi la Russie depuis Napoléon et
après et donc je comprends si on se met
du côté russe je peux comprendre que si
on leur dit B l'Ukraine va rentrer dans
le temps et on va mettre des missiles
pas sur le territoire ukrainien c'est
une menace directe maintenant les choses
ont changé la guerre en Ukraine elle a
eu le mérite de faire un progrès de de
de faire un progrès technologique énorme
et d'une façon différente de voir la
guerre on voit que par exemple tout ce
qui est cavalerie les chars les blindés
et cetera ça a pas été ça a été inutile
relativement inutile c'est les missiles
Javelin ont détruit des chars qui
valaient plus de 1 million et demi
d'euros même les derniers char russes où
il y avait personnes embarquées ils ont
pas fait floress et et inversement on a
vu aussi que nos charanous bon ça ça
n'avait pas amené un avantage décisif
donc donc on voit par contre que ce qui
a été décisif c'est tout ce qui est
drone ça ça a été on a révolutionné
aussi la façon on a ubérisé la façon de
taper une cible en ce sens que quand on
pointe au laser une cible on a un choix
on l'illumine on l'illumine on a un
choix de solution de tir comme si on
avait un choix de uber de taxi uber et
on va choisir le la solution de tir qui
est la plus appropriée pour pouvoir
toucher la cible et ça se fait à peu
près en 1 minute 30 en moyenne c'est
énorme je veux dire le progrès qui a eu
à ce niveau-là c'est énorme
et et donc on c'est à la fois une guerre
de tranchée à la fois une guerre de
drone mais dans laquelle il y a eu des
avancées technologiques et des une façon
de comprendre un conflit comme ça aussi
puissant comme on l'a jamais fait en
terme de lecture en terme de
renseignement on était préparé on était
pas préparé comment ça se passe on a été
briefé par Burns de la CIA le patron de
la CIA de l'époque qui est maintenant
est est parti euh et il savait tout y
compris que l'avion avec les commandos
russes allait atterrir pas loin de Kief
parce qu'il préparait d'attaquer la
présidence tout d'accord et c'est pour
ça aussi qu'ils sont fait choper dès le
départ
euh on peut pas il y a pas eu de
surprise et quand il y a pas d'ffit sur
prise il y a pas eu d'avantage du côté
russe voà je parle pas je parle des
Français alors les Français ils y ont
pas cru c'est qui c'est qui bah la DGSE
il y a pas cru la DGSE la DRM il y a pas
cru ils sont dit bah c'est comme en Irak
ils nous refont le coup de l'Irak bon
euh il y avait aucun intérêt à refaire
le coup de l'Irak l'Irak oui l'Irak il y
a eu toute une une mise en scène qui a
été faite parce que l'idée c'était de
mettre le main sur les ressources
pétrolières ce qui a été raté c'est pas
pour les écoles et mince alors l'Ukraine
il y a pas l'Ukraine qu'est-ce que c'est
on a une population qui est
vieillissante qui a du mal à se
renouveler qui est peu productive les
infrastructures elles sont dans un état
mais il faut voir c'est arrête de parler
avec un accent suisse c'est c'est c'est
c'est plus de 50 ans je veux dire c'est
et c'est surtout un pays qui est
contrôlé par la
mafia de A à Z où il y a une corruption
monumentale on va pas on va pas faire de
diffamation sur diffamation pas de
dénigrement aucun problème mais il y a
différentes personnalités comme monsieur
akmetov qui a une propriété qui est une
des plus chères de France la plus chère
de France il a la plus chère à Londres
il a la plus chère en Suisse il a
commencé sa carrière comme étant garçon
bouché c'est quoi tes sources parce que
c'est ton voisin tu connais sa fille
alors il se trouve que c'est quelqu'un
qui a créé pas mal d'émotions dans dans
sa carrière et donc il est connu et
euh les les différents groupes
Ukrainiens sont aussi marqués
culturellement et religieusement il y a
des des Tatars qui sont plutôt musulmans
il y a des Juifs il y a et cetera il y a
différentes catégories et il se trouve
que je vais pas donner trop de détail
mais j'en ai un qui était un une
personnalité qui avait une des plus
riches d'Ukraine qui a plusieurs
propriétés en France dont une à côté de
chez moi donc prend
AV et donc c'était quand même c'était
quand même intéressant de voir ça de la
façon dont il a pu dont ils ont pu tous
blanchir ou acquérir des propriétés à
l'étranger alors que ils sont recherchés
et et condamné dans certains cas en
terme de droit international c'est pour
les pauvres en Afrique le droit
international ou c'est aussi pour nous
ouais c'est pour les faibles le droit
international ne s'applique pas ça c'est
clair moi ça c'est c'est c'est vraiment
euh prenons et encore même parlons un
peu de l'Afrique parce qu'on va passer à
d'autres conflès après après mais bon
après mais mais il y a plein il y a un
conflit au Soudan par exemple qui dure
enfin les les deux dernières années ont
été particulièrement dures
euh des
des milliers de morts plus que centaines
de milliers de morts 3 millions de de
personnes en souffrance à l'heure
actuelle qui ont qui ont rien à bouffer
euh ça n n'a pas fait une ligne dans la
presse alors que le conflit
israëlo-palestinien où il y a beaucoup
moins ça fait bien sûr ça fait de la
parler c'est tout c'est normal ce qu'on
en parle mais voilà le Soudan par
exemple c'est un exemple c'est des
Africains qui se battent entre eux ça
n'intéresse pas on en parle pas toi en
tant que technicien de surface
oui
comment tu perçois
l'attitude l'ambiguité strégique de
notre président aimé chéri charismatique
Emmanuel
Macron c'est un grand stratège de guerre
non et je pense qu'il est un peu mal
conseillé quand même je pense que et
pour l'avoir vu aussi quand j'étais au
Niger moi j'ai fait le Niger de 2013 à
2020 pendant toute la période où j'étais
au Niger je voyais bien ce qui se
passait je voyais à quel point on
faisait des erreurs et à quel point
avait une bande d'escroc qui
venait dépouiller ce pays français qui
ont profité de la situation pour venir
prendre directement dans les caisses de
l'État euh et je et moi j'informais la
brigade financière à Paris j'informais
de ce que je voyais voilà il y a jamais
eu de
suite et je pense à un moment je leur ai
dit mais c'est pas possible pour que des
décisions comme ça soi pris c'est que
les rapports sont pas bons ça remonte il
y a quelque chose qui se passe et encore
récemment je peux pas en parler mais il
s'est passé quelque chose qui m'a fait
réagir et j'ai envoyé moi la
documentation concernant un pays bien
particulier dans lequel le président a
fait un voyage et je pense qu'il aurait
pas dû aller là-bas et
et c'est la Mongolie mais j'en dirais
pas tellement plus l'uranium c'est ça
alors justement il y en a pas merde
voilà la Mongolie c'est un satellite
russe les Russes sont pas des imbéciles
ils ont des ingénieurs et tout ça ils
ont des géologues ils savent très bien
détecter l'uranium ils l'ont fait bien
avant nous euh en en donc j'ai donné
tout un rapport sur Medvedev qui était
Président à l'époque en 2009 qui est
allé là-bas euh et qui a fait le constat
que il fallait sourcer voir s'il y avait
sourcer l'uranium il y en a pas euh et
euh il y a une
société puisqu'on en parle euh qui est
mentionné dans
le qui est mentionné V ici comment tu
sais hein il y a une société qui
s'appelle East minerals euh qui a acheté
des licences pour quelques milliers de
de dollars on parle de moins de 100000
d'accord quelques mois
après Areva qui existait à l'époque l'a
payé 65 million
d'euros qui qui a pris les sous et
l'argent a été ça a pas été payé en
action ça a été payé en cashin et donc
après derrière et et et le le c'était
rageant parce que le CEO de l'époque de
de cette société hisas minéral il
s'appelait Hawkins il a dit ah bah voyez
je suis c'est la plus belle opération à
peine on achète des licences qu'on les a
revendu bon et donc quand on voit le
le le compte-rendu de la le le l'accord
qui a été signé entre le parquet et au
rano il y a bien mention d'Asia minerals
il y a pas mention du fait que on a
acheté euh 65 million d'euros des
licences qui ont été achetées 6 mois
avant 100000 dollars voilà ça bien et
donc puisqu'on en parle moi j'ai réagi
j'ai fait l'information pour j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour le procureur
bonert qui est un homme que qui a fait
ce qu'il pouvait au niveau du PNF et qui
est intègre on peut pas lui reprocher de
pas être intègre c'est pas facile d'être
patron du PNF du financi voilà euh et
donc moi j'ai fait l'information avec la
partie russe voilà c'est un sacéellite
Russe ils savent très bien ce qu'il y a
nous ça fait depuis ça fait plus de 20
ans que depuis 95 que Areva à l'époque
travaillait sur la Mongolie sans jamais
sortir mais pas un des coudre d'accord
d'uranium donc là il y a eu un un pilote
qui a été fait pour aller chercher de
l'uranium et cetera ils ont ce qu'ils
ont réussi à produire en 18 mois c'est
l'équivalent de de ce qu'on produit au
Kazakhstan toujours chez chez Orano en
en une demi-journée voilà et donc quand
on nous dit on va investir un milliard
et demi en Mongolie non il faut dire au
français non on a besoin d'argent
aujourd'hui don on va pas faire ça
d'accord on va pas investir un milliard
et demi en Mongolie c'est pas possible
parce qu'on va sortir les documents ce
que j'ai donné moi je l' je c'est ça
reste propriété maintenant defin c'est
le ministère de l'Intérieur qui le gère
et j'espère que il se rendent compte euh
à quel point allez peut-être qu'ils ont
été enfumés un peu hein
euh peut-être qu'il y a eu des
erreurs soyons indulgent euh mais ce
développement là peut pas se faire plus
ça peut pas se faire aussi parce que en
face Poutine il est toujours là et donc
produire même si on arrivait à produire
de l'uranium en Mongolie c'est quoi les
routes de sortie c'est quoi les routes
de sortie on est bien d'accord et donc
il il appuie sur le bouton ça sort plus
la Russie en Mongolie a une ambassade de
consulat je ve c'est ça ils connaissent
le pays c'est chez eux le la Mongolie la
première langue c'est le russe le site
d'orano en Mongolie c'est une filiale il
est en russe et on voit sur le
d'ailleurs sur le site j'ai envoyé une
photo du site au ministère de
l'intérieur parce queil y a marqué
dessus un des gisements un des gisements
de classe mondiale le gisement de classe
mondiale c'est exactement ce qu'on
disait pour laffireuramine voilà
bon et et donc
alors quand on s'est vu là il y a
longtemps je venait de sortir l'homme
qui en savait beaucoup trop qui était
sur toutes les fraudes d'Areva
maintenant tu en sais beaucoup voilà et
après maintenant j'ai eu j'ai eu madame
louvergeon qui a été la seule d'ailleurs
m'a fait h procès elle a perdu les h
procès en tout sur toute la durée les
quatre derniers ça a été jugé il y a pas
tellement longtemps et pourquoi tu
embêtes cette dame et ben oui c'est
voilà mais pourquoi et et et ce qui est
important c'est que aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont mis en examen
dans la catégorie des frudsara il y a
beaucoup de gens mis en examen ce qui ne
veut pas dire et j'entends j'entends
peut-être des bruits des rumeurs on va
peut-être pas dire on va peut-être pas
tu sais que les bruit les rumeurs et les
bruits de couleur ici ça n'a aucune
valeur voilà et est-ce qu'on mettrait
pas ça sous le tapis non mais non vous
allez payer l'électricité extrêmement
cher donc on peut plus dire au français
payer sans leur dire pourquoi il payent
prenons cas de flamandville la Cour des
comptes vient de sortir un rapport on
voit que flamandville au départ c'est 3
milliards on arrive à 23 milliards donc
il y a 20 milliards d'écart d'accord
est-ce que dans ces 20 milliards il y a
eu des fraudes il faut bien payer les
restau Marc il y a eu
laaffiretil et on a laissé tomber on a
fait la prescription 10 ans laffire
voilà bon et ben vous payez l'affaire in
point quand Areva signe le contrat EDF
signe son contrat avec les les
Britanniques pour inkle
point ils vont racheter British Energy
très cher pourquoi c'est ton c'est ton
point de vue c'est mon point de
vue le directeur financier de DF
démissionne comment il s'appelait j'ai
plus son nom en tête mais il démissionne
et il dit moi je veux pas participer à
ça je je il l'a dit a des trac ah oui
c'est clair c'est clair et net il a
vraiment il a je te le répète tout ce
que tu dis pas de problème la Cour des
comptes la Cour des comptes aujourd'hui
a informé le public que dans les comptes
de DF il y avait 11 milliards de
provisions sur inclle
point c'est combien la dette de DF ah
oui bah oui mais voilà et donc est-ce
que vous allez payer l'électricité plus
chère oui pourquoi parce que il y a ça à
payer tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps pourquoi il y a ça tout le
temps parce qu'on crèvee pas l'absès
parce qu'il y a pas cette ordonnance de
renvoi qui soit qui per de juger les
gens et SS sont coupables alors qu'ils
ont la présomption d'innocence on le
répète s'ils sont coupables il faut
quand même faire un exemple non il faut
rendre justice juste il faut rendre
justice mais oui mais c'est ça mais mais
on peut pas on peut pas continuer à
avoir une industrie qui est l'industrie
nucléaire qui dit ben moi vous avez vos
lois ok c'est bien et puis nous on a on
fait on fait à côté celui qui s'est mis
en retrait c'est Thomas comment il
s'appelle j'ai plus son nom en tête
honnêtement mais mais il était il était
si faut de de DF et il a eu beaucoup de
courage he parce que c'est quand même un
poste exposé bon évidemment il a
retrouvé du travail derrière sans
problème mais c'est courageux de sa part
de se dire de dire moi je veux pas
revenir dans ce schéma là je je je
préfère arrêter là revenons au début de
la conversation la remontée
d'information de terrain oui le
technicien de surface il doit faire
remonter des informations brutes sans
interprétation on
comment ça se passe quand ça
remonte il faut que l'analyse soit bonne
donc neutre l'analyse elle est bonne
elle est neutre si elle est bien
documentée s'il y a une base historique
de temps en temps bien avec un réseau
local écrire quelque chose sur un
endroit où on a jamais été c'est jamais
bon parce qu'on a pas le sentiment même
si on a entendu même si on a les
contacts et cetera il faut y aller il
faut voilà voilà il faut il faut être
dedans ons le cas de la
Roumanie la Roumanie tu parles les
élections oui les élections les
élections
présidentielles moi je suis pas
proorusse du tout Poutine est une merde
tant pis pour la diffamation mais je
regarde la Roumanie je je je l'ai un peu
dans mon cœur parce que les j'ai
travaillé beaucoup avec des légionnaires
qui étaient d'origine roumaine il faut
voir que non il faut savoir que à la
Légion étrangère il y a un contingent de
Roumains qui à peu près le de deè
d'accord et c'est des gens extrêmement
attachants c'est des gens fiers de leur
pays les Roumains c'est des traces c'est
ceux qui ont font des Romes c'est pas
des bons à rien il y a rien à voir entre
les Roumains et les Romes d'accord c'est
c'est les Romes ne sont pas des bons à
rien non plus c'est pas des bons à rien
non plus mais mais c'est voilà on peut
comprendre pourquoi c'est un peuple qui
a une fierté mais il a énormément
souffert ce peuple
et ceux que je connais ils ont été
jeunes sous chaouescou ils ont fait la
queue dans la rue dans le froid pour
avoir un bout de pain parce que
chaochescou tout ce qui il exportait
tout et pour son peuple il y avait rien
et pour sortir de cette misère là ils
ont pris le risque de se faire tué en
traversant les frontières à l'époque il
y avait quand même une frontière qui
était qui était très surveillée pour
venir jusqu'en France en France il
trouve la Légion ils sont acceptés dans
la légion alors que la Légion c'est 10 %
et au sein de la Légion ils vont au
2uxème
REP donc c'est quand même des gens très
respectables d'accord
on leur a montré les valeurs
républicaines dans la légion on leur a
montré comment on pouvait disons comment
on vivait comment ils ont eu ils ont pas
eu une éducation au sens universitaire
on leur a pas fait faire des grandes
études mais ils ont vu que comment ça
vivait la France c'est ça l'intégration
de la Légion c'est pas seulement l'armée
c'est aussi le vivre
ensemble et donc il fut un très bon rosé
d'ailleurs oui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
quand on voit les élections en Roumanie
il y a d'anciens de la Légion qui sont
derrière d'accord qui étaient derrière
le président bon alors celui qui a été
élu mais pas élu mais voilà celui qui a
été élu et et les journaux ont dit ah
mais c'est l'extrême droite c'est des
néonazis c'est les prrusses et les
machins non il y a eu il y a eu
peut-être une infiltration russe
peut-être elle a pas été elle a pas été
prouvée il y a pas moi j'ai rien vu de
de probant mais admettons qu'il y a eu
une infiltration russe est- est-ce que
derrière est-ce que derrière dans les 20
% notamment il y a des gens qui sont des
néonazis et des prorusses moi je dis non
je les connais il y a eu des gens qui
ont été désespérés par la corruption
roumaine et qui ont été disons attiré
par l'aspect extrême droite viril et
Machin on ah on est les hommes et on va
on va régler les problèmes on va régler
aucun problème d'accord et quand on leur
parle le problème de c'est la corruption
ils en ont
ralbol de voir les femmes abandonner
leurs enfants à l'étranger pour que
l'enfant ait un avenir ils en ont ralbol
d'aller dans un hôpital et filer une
enveloppe parce que sinon s'il y a pas
l'enveloppe il y a pas de soins ils en
ont ralbol de tout ça ils en ont rbol de
voir des forêts primaires qui sont
magnifique dans le Nord et se faire
dépouiller voilà et donc au bout d'un
moment et ben le ralbol fait que on va
sur du dur mais c'est pas du tout des
gens et je l'ai encore une fois c'est
ces hommes hommes là ils sont hyper
entraînés s'il voulait faire un coup
d'étail il le feraiit comme ça sans
aucun problème donc tout ce qu'ils
veulent c'est un espoir quelle était ma
question je me souviens plus c'était
l'analyse voilà c'était l'analyse
comment on fait l'anyse par la Romanie
parce que ça m'a parce que ça m'a
c'était quoi ma question mais mais parce
que euh du dur du dur quand il est sur
le terrain il fait remonter son on
reviendra sur la Romanie
voà faut oui on a le temps oui bonne
année celui qui traite l'officier
traitant oui pourquoi il il démissionne
pas comme celui de DF en disant voilà
moi je fais je transmets de
l'information il a quand même son son
son libre arbitre il voit bien que le
côté
opérationnel ça marche pas trop pourquoi
il démissionne pas alors il il peut se
retrouver sur une voie de garage un
placard ouais bien sûr euh mais en fait
l'officier traitant il a un rapport avec
l'homme de terrain qui est le même
rapport qu'un cheval avec son cavalier
l'officier traitant c'est le cavalierou
mais un cavalier de C sa d'obstacle de
dressage d'endurance il peut avoir un
pur s dans les mains ça c'est clair et
et sur place il y a un gars qui est là
et qui va qui va qui qui va et donc le
job de l'officier traitant c'est de de
tenir les rennes un tout petit peu et et
de corriger un peu si ça va pas dans le
bon sens sens mais il faut qu'en dessous
la bête elle donne ouais non mais elle
donne elle donne d'autant plus quand tu
corriges pas c'est juste un détail
revenons à l'échelle au dessus donc
l'officier traitant a synthétisé ce qu'
faisait ce qu' pouvait remonter pas
toujours pas
d'interprétation le moins possible
d'accord donc ça passe à l'échelon
supérieur moi je voudrais que tu me
parles de de l'échelon on interprète on
source on triangule on fait de la
prospective on fait de l'analyse on fait
remonter à Monsieur le Ministre alors on
tri on triangule on fait de l'analyse et
tout ça tu fais des bulles un peu ou pas
des bulles c'est-à-dire trianguler et tu
fais des
bulles on triangule au niveau de c'est à
tous les étages même même sur le terrain
je veux dire on va on va jamais donner
une information si on l'a pas vérifié
plusieurs fois je c'est c'est et et on
vérifie de pas se faire
manipuler mais encore heureux euh mais
ça reste de l'humain donc l'humain c'est
bon c'est fragile
euh et il peut y avoir des tromperies et
il y en a dans dans l'histoire du
renseignement il y en a des belles le
profil psychologique de ceux qui font du
renseignement de terrain et de ceux qui
font du renseignement de bureau c'est
quoi ah bah c'est complètement différent
alors là c'est le le le profil du
terrain c'est quelqu'un déjà
euh qui a pas besoin de confort qui a
pas
besoin de se préoccuper
euh il doit il doit être libre des
préoccupations familiales libre de de de
de de toute considération et il doit se
concentrer sur sa mission s'il le fait
pas il se met en danger son job ça va
être de lever aussi des réseaux pour
pouvoir croiser ses
information et et
donc et d'apprendre le terrain
d'apprendre d'apprendre d'apprendre le
terrain la couleur du sable tout
d'apprendre le terrain parce que c'est
comme ça qu'il arrivera à s'en
sortir moi j'ai toujours travaillé
souvent seul et et sur le
terrain et ben c'est épuisant parce qu'à
chaque fois il faut tout euh gérer par
soi-même et et la dernière fois où j'ai
eu une difficulté euh
ouais gros moment de solitude tu étais
sous contrat ou tu étais euh non non non
non non j'étais j'étais en train de
sourcer des documents euh sur la
corruption et euh et ça failli très très
mal finir mais ça c'est le
jeu c'est le jeu c'est comme euh
prenons le le d'ailleurs je lui déd
cette interview si ça te gêne pas
Sylvain Mercadier c'est un journaliste
qui est
indépendant qui a un jeune il a une
trentaine même pas qui s'est fait
attraper en Syrie alors qu'il regardait
ce que faisait l'armée israélienne en
Syrie bon et il s'est pris des claques
bon donc humiliation euh et puis c'est
un jeune donc il a le sang chaud moi je
j'auris la bouteille he c'est j'ai
l'habitude ça s'est bien terminé pour
lui on lui a rendu son matériel il s'en
sort il y a pas de souci mais voilà non
il a pas rendu mais c'est c'est un c'est
quelqu'un qui veut travailler comme
Joseph kessell le faisait dans dans le
passé et c'est quelqu'un qui a une plume
en plus qui est qui est
magnifique je pense que dans dans 5 ou
10 ans cet homme-là il sera au top on le
verra au top pu s'il écrit des livres
moi je les recommande j'ai déjà vu sa
plume vraiment c'est c'est très bien ce
qu'il fait et il a cœur d'aller sur le
terrain de sentir voilà la sueur coulée
à l'odeur du sang pour faire quelque
chose de bien c'est un journaliste
honorable contributeur on peut pas dire
Sylvain mercalier c'est vraiment pas du
tout un agent c'est le journaliste mais
qui en veut qui veut qui veut qui a le
goût de l'aventure quand même hein euh
et qui fait le travail que ferait un
agent c'est un peu la même chose quand
même sauf que lui euh bah c'est juste
pour écrire des papiers euh alors que
moi c'est pour régler des comptes quand
même non c'est pour protéger la France
oui
reviens reviens sur la le corps de la
question donc là technicien de surface
il a fait remonter son voyage de
vacances si je résume trivialement oui
c'est des nouveaux touristes
oui bien sûr et donc B non tu les vois
il y a des moments où c'est il y a des
moments où c'est plaisant ouais oui puis
il y a des moments où c'est rigolo non
allez je vais vous raconter une
anecdote
bregnef Léonide bregneev qui était
dirigeant rus russe aimet deux choses le
whisky et les films de John
Wayne et il y a un agent Suisse qui
amenait à brege nef au fils qui passait
par le fils qui amenait à Breg nef
régulièrement sa dose de s ses
bouteilles et et ses films
bon et il avait la conviction qu'en fait
breneev aurait jamais rien fait contre
les États-Unis parce que il était quand
même assez accro à la culture américaine
de ce fait-là alors peut-être que
j'exagère un peu mais c'est quand même
amusant de voir ça que ça se faisait
derrière en sous-marin alors que
bregenev donnait une image de vraiment
le soviétique dur et ferme comment je te
coupe comment c'est ça ta blague
marrante non c'est une
anecdote j'espère que l'agent Suisse
m'en voudra pas de la raconter mais il y
a pas de raison maintenant quand tu vois
Trump livrer à Poutine des masques et
des respirateurs c'est du même maabi
c'est est-ce que c'est les vieilles
filières non non c'est c'est autre chose
c'est vraiment non non ces filières là
non non qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
vieille filière alors il y a des
filières par exemple il faut se rendre
compte et moi je l'ai appris il y a il y
a il y a peu de temps il y a moins de de
d'un an euh que la technologie qui
allait au Qatar par exemple allait à
than que pourquoi parce que l'Iran et le
Qatar c'est des frères siamois ils sont
liés par un champ de gaz qui s'appelle
southp pour l'Iran nor SP pour le Qatar
et et donc ce champ c'est un des plus
gros champ gazier au monde ça fait la
richesse du Qatar ça fait aussi des
revenus hyper importants pour l'Iran et
de ce fait là on a beau dire c'est des
sunites c'est des chiites ça c'est de la
c'est de la fouaise ils sont liés par ça
et les agents iraniens les agents
Qataris se rencontrent à DOA
régulièrement dans l'aéroport dans le le
bâtiment d'ailleurs qui a été construit
par des Français qui est là où seront
qui est dédié à la famille royale euh et
euh et donc il y a un échange complet
euh de ce que on peut amener en
technologie au Qatar ça ça partira en
Iran c'est comme ça aussi que l'Iran
fait des progrès énormes et a la Chine
aussi non ouais ils ont ils ont ils ont
euh ils ont des services qui sont
compétents on a vu aussi qu'ils avaient
réussi à infiltrer le PFL azuric euh
assez brillamment euh ils sont mis sur
le parking non ils ont créé une start-up
qui permettait de d'avoir des
technologies euh
occidental c'est tout bête le corps de
la question principale donc ton analyse
de T ton technicien de surface il te
faire monter ensuite c'est traité c'est
remonté le plus neutre possible ouais
ensuite ça arrive où alors de temps ça
peut aller très vite ça peut aller
directement au
président après il faut que l'agent il
soit habilité à faire ça il faut que il
est pas fauté il faut que ça soit clair
il faut qu'il soit compétent et que sa
compétence soit ir connu il y a un
problème justement de de timing dans
certains cas il faut que l'information
remonte vite et donc ça
après on peut juger qu'elle est pas
suffisante on peut juger qu'elle est pas
bonne on peut juger tout ce qu'on veut
mais l'information peut remonter vite
d'accord et donc
oui ça ça peut aller comme ça
directement d'accord donc le président
tu sais notre président qui joue à pppp
boington en mettant des suits des des
des commandos avec une barbe de 3 jours
il a des compétences il a pas de
compétences pour traiter ça il a des
conseillers quels sont les
conseillers
alors on remarque que notre président il
est assez jeune on est d'accord ça ça
n'empêche pas
il est assez jeune je le défends pas toi
tu as 25 ans oui il est assez jeune on
va me dire oui mais il est pas compétent
il est M c'est Macron caca Macron ok euh
Trump 78 ans
netanahou 75 ans Poutine 73 x Jinping 71
euh Indira modi en Inde 71 tous des
setuagénè qui vont vous dire je prépare
le
futur moi je préfère avoir un président
plus jeune pourquoi parce qu'il a moins
de déficience cognitive qu'est-ce que
c'est la déficience cognitive c'est la
capacité d'apprendre au-delà de 70 ans
le cerveau vieillit et donc on perd
graduellement les capacités cognitives
la capacité d'apprendre bon euh donc 70
ans Trump 78 ans Trump et bah bon
courage pour travailler avec lui
d'accord et on l'a vu ce que ça donnait
avec Biden pour moi Trump ou Biden c'est
la même chose hein c'est voilà nous on a
la chance d'avoir un Macron qui est
jeune et qui a une capacité de travail
importante ça n'excuse rien il a fait
des erreurs ok ok quelles étaient les
erreurs ok la dissolution les la façon
de
travailler maintenant tous les PR
président et tous les premiers ministres
qu'on
aura jusqu'à ce qu'on ait payé les
dettes seront imppulaires non mais
toujours alors tu crois qu'on va payer
notre dette oui non mais soit on paye
notre dette soit on est obligé de sortir
de la zone euro et on aura une monnaie
de
singe toi moi j'ai des billets dans mon
bureau j'ai des billets de 50 milliards
de dollars zimbabweéens 100 milliards de
dollars Zimbabwe 1 tout ça bon avec ça
on pouvait même pas acheter une baguette
de pain d'accord brochette de rat rien
tu la connais la brochette de rat ouais
pou même pas faire ça et donc et donc je
souhaite à personne vivre dans un pays
où il y a ce genre de problème la
monnaie elle doit rester stable on a une
monnaie stable parce qu'on a l'Euro
aujourd'hui parce que c'est l'euro qui
nous a permis de nous endetter tu te
trompes tu te trompes on a une monnaie
stable notre économie a été sauvée parce
que on a Bruno Le Maire oui aussi ou oui
certainement mais
euh mais trêv de plaisanterie la la
dette c'est le ver n'est pas une
plaisanterie la dette est un sujet
extrêmement grave moi j'ai connu un
chipriote qui s'est retrouvé le vendredi
soir on leur dit bah voilà les banques
ferment le lundi matin il avait plus
d'argent sur son compte et je souhaite
pas ça à la France il lui restait un
petit peu tu es mauvaise langue ça a été
ça a été un carnage quand même hein ton
copain chipriote il était russe non non
il était grec chipriote et et donc moi
je
euh je veux bien qu'on ait des gens très
impopulaire euh prenons ellisabeth borne
qui a un parcours personnel remarquable
pupille de la nation polytechnicienne et
cetera remarquable d'accord qu'on la
traîne dans la boue qu'on dise que c'est
elle est mauvaise et cetera ok elle a
fait la réforme des retraites ça suffira
pas mais elle l'a fait elle a pris le le
le choix de l'impopular
moi j'aimerais bien qu'en France on a
une présidente un jour si ça doit être
mais qu'on est une présidente et c'est
mais de toute façon cette présidente là
ou il sera imppulaire parce qu'il faut
couper il faut couper la dette il faut
baisser sinon mais on c'est l'avenir de
nos enfants et je dirais l'avenir des 40
ans voilà de cette tranche d' de 0 à 40
qu'on qu'on entre on enterre leur avenir
ils en ont
zéro donc bah oui ça imppulaire bon faut
accepter voilà c'est le service de la
France
bon tu connais des
médecins très peu je fréquente pas
beaucoup les tu t quand tu étais dans
tes petits dans tes petits camp de
vacances un peu partout dans le monde tu
t'es déjà fait une petite septicémie un
début de grande graine une dent malade
alors j'ai eu j'ai eu moi qui torsion de
testicule j'ai eu j'ai eu l'occasion
malheureusement deéovi ça non non non d'
d'être joyeusement empoisonné par
différentes nourriture au point de de de
se retrouver avec un ventre énorme et ça
c'est donc merci au au médecins chinois
qu'on trouve dans les villages qui ont
des des médecins des des médicaments
complètement périmés mais c'est une
planche de salut merveilleuse quand même
parce que quand on a rien c'est
terrible la premier le premier jour où
j'atterris au Niger dans le désert
d'Agadem je vois un gars qui est allongé
sur une table
et qui a
laappindicite et qui hurle d'accord il
souffre
beaucoup et donc je mais qu'est-ce qu'il
a
l'appendicite vous l'emmenez pas il y a
pas un traitement il y a pas
ou il y a un camion qui a des des des
des boulons à amener à dia et donc on va
peut-être l'emmener avec le camion à dia
et puis le camion en fait il avait pas
envie de faire un petit détour il y
avait un quart d'heure de détour à faire
il a pas fait le détour et le gars il
est mort 2 he après dans les hurlements
voilà bon ça au bout d'un moment il
s'est arrêté h terminé voilà et là pour
un premier jour je me suis dit ouf si
jamais il arrive quelque chose la vie
humaine ne vaut rien il y aura zéro aide
zéro rien voilà c'est tu pars dans ce
type de région est-ce que tu prends par
exemple des choses à troquer on dit tout
le temps que les les agents secrets se
baladent avec des Rolex ça leur permet
d'acheter des billets d'avion non alors
déjà parce que moi je j'évite de payer
d'accord euh je préfère avoir un rapport
humain avec la personne si je vois une
source intéressante euh j'essaie de de
voir comment et pourquoi elle va
m'amener de l'information pour comment
allez comment elle peut m'être utile he
faut être faut être clair et j'évite de
payer pourquoi parce que c'est comme la
torture quand on torture les gens ils
raconent n'importe quoi pour qu'on
arrête quand on paye il raconte
n'importe quoi pour qu'on continue bon
et donc c'est pas un bon rapport il faut
le bon rapport c'est dire bah voilà ça
m'est arrivé d'avoir mais c'est
difficile d'en parler parce que bon les
relations avec le nigerre ce qu'elles
sont
euh gr grâce à ah oui euh personne qui
souffre voilà bah on essaie d'avoir de
lui
proposer un travail pour sa famille on
essaie d'être un peu accommodant euh il
voit venir gros comme une maison quoi
allez si c'est un artisan on va lui
acheter quelque chose on va le voir on
lui achète quelque chose donc on va
collectionner des
trucs et pour mais et voilà et on essaie
de lier on essaie d'être le gars sympa
on essaie d'être le gars qui va donner
une solution dans un pays où le on vit
un on vit comme il y a 2000 ans et où la
pauvreté est telle que les gens mangent
pas une fois par jour c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'il faut comprendre et
euh le Niger une famille c'est un homme
trois femmes 20 gosses hein en brousse
c'est ça
euh le nombre de femmes qui sont mortes
parce qu'elles arrivent pas à accoucher
moi j'en ai vu beaucoup qui est-ce qui a
aussi provoqué ça et ben quand on a fait
tomber Kaddafi Kaddafi finançait toute
l'Afrique de l'Ouest et notamment
attends atts attends attends qui a fait
tomber kadfi la
France et là on était payé par le Qatar
on y reviendra euh mais quand on fait
tomber Kaddafi on fait tomber tout le
système de santé du Mali et du Niger
parce que les centres de santé intégré
ce qu'on appelait les CSI qui sont en
bruse c'est les petits trucs en brous
hein étit payé par kadfi kadfi savait
très bien qu'il fallait pas euh qu'il
fallait maintenir ça pour éviter qu'il y
ait une montée de la population nous
quand on fait tomber kadfi on fait
tomber toutes les front
et on fait tomber toutes les barrières
qui et on crée une masque migratoire
comme on en a jamais
créé c'est ça la bêtise et donc quand
Gérard Longuet ministre de la Défense
vient devant l'Assemblée quand il est
quand on il y a la guerre qui éclate
avec la Libye et il dit voilà on va
dépenser 300 millions mais les 300
millions et là j'ai le document les 300
millions on les prend pas sur le budget
de la
défense on on va les prendre sur les
budgets d'iver
voilà mais
surréaliste on les prend pas sur le
budget de la défense pour aller faire la
guerre en Libye et les gens croient ça
les députés croient ça or on a eu un
document qui date du 23 novembre 2010 de
mémoire qui montre que le Qatar a
financé le la guerre en Libye pour ces
300 millions là et il a fallu que
j'aille à Jérusalem pour trouver un
arabe
qui examine le document euh et
clairement quelqu'un des des services
israéliens un ancien des services
israéliens et il me dit mais regarde il
y a il y a tout en bas de la page il y a
une toute petite écriture j'avais
personne n'a prêté attention et il y a
marqué ce document n'est fait qu'en un
seul
exemplaire et je dit mais alors je
comprends quand le juge sommeraire que
j'ai rencontré est allé chercher la
copie de ce document dans les archives
de l'Élysée il l'a pas trouvé quand il
est et donc on trouvait pas ce document
bah oui il a été fait qu'en un seul
exemplaire gardé par altani donc voilà
il est sorti comment cet exemplaire par
l'opérationprit Al il non non alors il
non c'est pas ça c'est une c'est une
grosse
opération d'acquisition de documents
et qui moi m'a fait écrire le livre
Raven le pacte du Qatar euh donc roman
mais qui col vraiment beaucoup à la à la
réalité qui est un peu la suite du
réseau parce qu'on retrouve les
personnages mais en fait c'est la quête
de ces documents là et je
montre bon comment Israël s'est fait
infiltrer comment on a pu la le carnage
que ça a été pour sourcer ces documentsl
qui les a voilà il a il y a tout encore
qui est il y a des personnes qui ont
beaucoup plus encore de que ces
documentsl dont un Américain euh et je
peux pas donner son nom parce qu'il est
maintenant du il il
il est payé par les cataris aujourd'hui
donc c'est quand même difficile mais il
est dans mon procès verbal euh et
euh et donc ça fait partie des
documents que des servic de
renseignement ont peut-être en tout tout
parti en tout cas les Émirats ont
beaucoup plus que ce qui n'a été publié
et qui change la face du monde en terme
de corruption parce qu'on se rend compte
à quel point le Qatar a corrompu pass
seulement du Parlement européen pas
seulement la FIFA mais Urby et Torbi et
j'ai eu un document exceptionnel de 260
pages à peu près qui est le le le
le le l'écrit d'un témoignage enregistré
devant des juges et la police le FBI aux
États-Unis euh et le le la personne qui
témoigne
euh a été dans le cercle intime de la
famille altani et il
raconte ce qu'il a vu il raconte
notamment par exemple qu'au niveau de la
presse c'est une enquête en cours ça non
alors non c'est plus en cours ça a été
jugé et donc le document c'est un
document qui est
parfaitement validé par la justice
américaine
euh je donne pas le nom de la personne
mais si je ça pas
d'intérêt la la à un moment il indique
voilà le une des un des objectifs
c'était de d'influencer la presse la
presse internationale et donc il cible
par pays les journaux qui les
intéressent les journalistes les
journaux qui les intéressent après il
s'intéresse à la façon de les infiltrer
les journalistes et il dit bah voilà on
paye entre 5000 dollars et 1
million le juge lui demande des noms et
tout ça bon alors il y a des noms qui
sont évoqués en France
pour la France il a une petite phrase la
la France était pas peu influente au
niveau de sa presse presse faible jugé
comme étant presse faible mais oui il y
a eu en France oui en 2016 notamment
ouais ouais vers
23h30
c'est je donnerai pas plus de détails
parce que ça va nous emmener dans dans
il faudrait que je puisse montrer les
documents à la caméra bon mais alors
l'émission va être relativent longue ce
soir donc on a beaucoup de temps je
voudrais ton avis sur la situation de la
France en termees géopolitique finances
et perspective tu donnes combien de
temps à la France pour qu'on se fasse
dégrader méchamment bah déjà sur le plan
financier on a une épée de d'amocles qui
commence à descendre sérieusement et là
vraiment elle touche le cuir
chevelu et il est pas question d'être
faible moi ma crainte absolue c'est de
voir un berou 73 ans euh usé
physiquement usé quand on le voit faire
son discours de politique général tu as
vu comment tu marches
toi encore
euh mesdames n'écoutez pas ça marche
très bien alors que François berou il a
l'air beaucoup plus usé
et et je défends mon premier ministre he
oui et et et ça ça fait un peu peur
parce qu'il va être tout le temps dans
le promis pour pas
tomber c'estàd c'est c'est la violence
molle ouais très la pertinence molle
voilà il y a il y a une urgence il y a
des coupes claires à faire c'est pas
populaire ça fait mal il faut le faire
on va couper le budget du
renseignement pour ce qui en eff fait
alors s'il faut mettons globalement le
budget de la défense 5 pour provoquer
j'espère que tu vas me dire mais non il
faut rajouter du budget parce que déjà
on a des me qui sont là on peut faire on
peut faire on peut faire de la qualité
on peut faire de la qualité sans
forcément avoir des budgets fou on peut
aussi aller chercher de l'argent privé
ce que ne fait pas la France euh non non
non très peu très peu il y a pas de
et aussi pourquoi
aller toujours se focaliser sur la
technologie sur l'informatique sur les
écoutes sur voilà est-ce qu'on peut pas
repenser le renseignement un peu un peu
autrement qu'au travers de quelque chose
qui est extrêmement consommateur de fond
par des gadgets non c'est pas des
gadgets mais quand on fait des écoutes à
grande échelle pour après réduire avec
des algorithmes et pour en sortir
quelque chose qu'onexpllooite pas
tellement
euh si on prend le cas des guerres dans
lesquelles la France a été engagée il y
a pas de guerre qu'est-ce que tu
racontes la libie la libie la Syrie et C
la Syrie c'est du passé pourquoi payer
autant pour avoir aussi peu d'efficacité
alors est-ce qu'il y a un petit rétex un
petit retour d'expérience un petit une
petite évaluation de bon bah là on a mis
quand même 150 € euh ah bah il y a pas
de retour quand même l'opération
Barc
2013-221 d'accord à peu près hein après
ça c'est c'est la 350
€ c'est entre selon les années entre 600
millions et 1 milliard par an le franç
FAA 2 € d'accord acccord et donc pour un
et zéro au bout tu es méchant tu es
mauvaise langu regarde on a que des amis
sur place on est invité à toutes les
soirées voilà donc on n' pas vu les
coups d'État au Mali bon voilà on on on
n' pas vu le coup d'État à Bazou mais
quand on voilà moi j'ai moi j'étais
encore là-bas quand donc Bazou est
devenu
Président j'ai vu en brousse les
échanges des urnes en fait les gens
allaient voter ok donc on pouvait avoir
un quelqu'un qui vérifiait que les gens
votaient il y a pas de problème on prend
les urnes on les dépouille pas sur place
on les amène quelque part et il y a un
échange des urnnes en brous avec les uns
de Bazou contre bon on peut me dire que
c'est le super Président j'ai vu aussi
le la mafia Zain un des membres de la
famille
Zain qui sont des des
Kurdes syriens qui sont des des
criminels enfin c'est une mafia
allemande maintenant euh qui venait
discuter le bout de gras avec
Bazou euh on a petit
Boubet petit Boubé aliasil férro qui a
un palais mais un palais en marbre blanc
tout ça avec tout ce qu'il faut les
voitures de luxe et tout le bardard il a
ici avenue Foche trois hôtels
particulier il investit bien son argent
et voilà donc courtier en armement
basseœuvre tout ce qu'on veut quand il y
a 100 millions d'euros qui sont
détournés du de la caisse du ministère
de la Défense nigérien on est là c'est
sourc carré oui la France est encore là
quand ça se passe et on en prend un
petit peu ou pas alors ce qui est
étonnant ça finance des partis
politiques ou pas ce que je suis en
train de dire on le retrouve dans un
livre qui s'appelle jeu de guerre que
j'ai publié grâce à Florent massau qui a
eu les le courage de le publier
euh et
dans le livre je cite aussi par exemple
très précisément que jean-lve ledrillant
à un moment vend des soucoiles des
avions soucoil d'attaque au sol au Niger
qui vendent des rafales ça me choque pas
qui vendent des soucoilles je me dis
tiens c'est
inventif les soucoilles sont payés 10
millions de dollars pièce non les deux B
c'est quand même des truc avec des
pilotes Ukrainiens que je voyais se
torcher avant de prendre
le il faut se détendre
100 millions de dollars sur les 100
millions il y a 2 millions qui partent
en commission sur des sociétés
offshore est-ce que c'est bien le job du
ministre de la défense de faire ça mais
tu as des sources là parce que tu es en
train d'incriminer quand même tout a été
écrit noir sur blanc dans jeu de guerre
le nom des sociétés tout tout d' et tu
as eu combien de procès pour ça zéro
parce qu'ils l'ont peut-être pas lu non
non non non la question a été posée à
Monsieur ledriillan aussi de sur à
propos de de
la de la guerre en en Syrie comment
daesh exportait son pétrole via une
société qui était basé à dortiol
française qui permettait au pétrole de
Dah de transportter de la fin du
terminal sur un bateau d'accord un
terminal pétrolier
d'accord ce pétrole allait en sardeigne
et allait en Israël bon j'ai été en
contact avec les procureurs italiens
pour leur donner les éléments que
j'avais moi d'accord j'ai été en aussi
avec des Israéliens qui m'ont dit oui on
avait un probl il y a un chapitre entier
sur ce cette histoire là d'enjeu de
guerre quand on a posé la question et
c'est la députée Frédérique Dumas à
l'époque qui a posé la question en
commission des affaires étrangères puis
question gouvernement quand elle était
député on pose la question à jeanience
sur ce qui s'est passé à ce moment-là
pourquoi une société française a aidé
daesh à exporter son pétrole pas de
réponse
il éit peut-être pas au courant du
dossier il a peut-être pas eu ton mail
il y a eu une enquête préliminaire qui a
été et et j'ai été en contact avec la
commissaire qui a démarré l'enquête il
peut-être l'enquête a été arrêtée voilà
moi j'ai pas eu d'ennui enfin peut-être
pas il y av peut-être pas suffisamment
de preuves donc ah bah surtout si on les
cherche pas en tout cas en Italie ils
ont cherché ils ont trouvé donc monsieur
ludriillon dans cette histoire il est
peut-être au courant de rien il il a
touché aucun sou ah bah j'ai pas dit
qu'il avait touché de l'argent j'ai dit
j'ai dit que daesh a exporté son pétrole
via une société française qui était àol
et cette société on la retrouve aussi à
Hati par exemple c'est une très belle
île c'est c'est marrant parce que Haïti
donc attends avant Haïti les deux
soucoilles tu me dis que le dillant a
vendu des soucoille ouis mais c'est
c'est pas le drillant avec sa carte de
visite
c'estétion c'est lui qui est allé voir
isoufu ça s'est fait sous isoufu à
l'époque il est allé voir isoufou oui et
tuas tu as les papiers transactionnel
signé de la main de de ludriillantou
alors pas de leudriillant mais j'ai j'ai
les sociétés offshore j'ai tout est dans
le livre pourquoi tu parles de
leudriillant parce que c'est lui qui
était le patron de la défense il a
peut-être pas
vu c'est lui qui a fait la tournée des
popotes au départ les avions il
voulaient les vendre au Congo après il a
été et puis ça s'est terminé au Niger
bon c'est quand même bizarre les pistes
elles sont suffisamment longue au Niger
pour faire décoller des soucoilles bon
au moins ça va servir mais ils étaient
basés à Zinder moi j'étais pas loin
voilà et donc est-ce que tu as vu des
avions français ou d'autres nationalités
avec des chargements un peu délicat en
terme de stupéfiant ah
bah le le Niger est une route de transit
où remontait on avait des GO fastes qui
où on mettait de la cocaïne quand on en
arrête voilà et c'est quand même assez
délicat et les les les soldats nigériens
avec lesquels j'étais euh disait bah non
ça c'est le pas toucher ça c'est le
business du président de qui de quel
président c'est le business du Président
c'est tout local ouais c'est le business
du Président c'est c'est voilà c'est on
touche pas bon il est clair que pays
pauvre donc il y a de la cam qui
transite ils prennent une com c'est tout
c'est la cam qui vient d'Amérique du Sud
c'est les nouvelles routes ouais c'est
les nouvelles routes ouais bon c'est
comme ça pourquoi tu t'intéresses comme
ça aux effet de corruption c'est parce
que tu es patriote ou parce qu'il y a du
fricass parce que c'est le l'arme
absolue la corruption
c'est il y a rien qui
résiste c'est pire que tout et donc une
fois que c'est dans la société une fois
que ça ça a bien gangrainé les piliers
ça s'effondre et là alors là c'est
terrible là on perd tout de 0 à 10 tu tu
évalues à combien l'état de corruption
de notre pays zé c'est on est déjà mort
10 on est digne d'un pays nordique
alors on est à
euh 45
ouais non mais non mais 45 ça veut rien
dire si en fait faut pas être non plus
faire du spectaculaire la police
antiorruption elle est elle est
nombreuse quand même parce qu'il y a il
y a différentes brigades il y a la
brigade financière il y a le CLUSIF et
cetera il y a la grande criminalité
financière euh alors c'est trop il
faudrait avoir une seule police comme un
FBI il faudrait intégrer tracf tracf
c'est sous la coupole de de s sous
l'autorité du ministère de des finances
alors que ça devrait être sous
l'intérieur à mon avis ça serait plus
efficace si tout le monde travaillait
ensemble il y aurait moins de problèmes
il y a il arrive dans certains cas que
les informations soient envoyer à à une
de ces autorités et que ça soit une
autre qui travaille sur le dossier et
donc ça il y a des il y a des impères
tuas une armoire forte chez
toi je donnerai pas de détail sur ma sur
ma sécurité sur ces éements là ça je les
grande ou les petites mais ça peut être
aussi logé ailleurs voilà
tu es prê tues tes contremesures pour
éviter de te faire surveiller sur place
tu
prends un téléphone qui se jette tu
téléphones pas tu fais auditer de temps
en temps tes tes périphériques comment
ça se passe parce que là tu m'as montré
ton téléphone portable tu me fais rire
oui mais je
je il faut faire attention au matériel
qu'on utilise quand on traverse une
frontière
quand on traverse une frontière avec un
matériel qui est notoirement ou quand on
va dans une
ambassade un matériel qui est
notoirement utilisé pour cacher des
informations
euh crypter un disque dur
CHR voilà chiffrer un disque dur
utiliser aussi un
cordon qui permet de déchiffrer ou qui
est nécessaire au déchiffrage voilà à un
moment il y avait la méthode stegano qui
était utilisé euh donc on retrouve un
stegano sur un PC stegano pour chiffrer
tu fais stegano c'était sympa parce que
ça permettait pour pour les néophites ça
permettait en fait c'est un logiciel qui
permet d'intégrer dans une photo un
message qui peut être plus ou moins long
d'accord euh et donc un pixel ouais
ouais on change les pixels d'une photo
voilà et donc j'envoie à la personne euh
cette photo
euh donc pour beaucoup de gens je veux
dire c'est une
photoésent voilà du président Macron
alors qu'en
fait reçoit des chiffres et voit que
dans la photo évidemment il y a des
Pixelles qui ont été modifié et qu'il y
a un message ça a été utilisé notamment
par alqaïda et donc ça posait un
problème parce que quand on envoyait des
photos pixelisé enfin des photos
stegano et ben ça faisait sonner pas mal
d'alertes ce qui faisait que ça
augmentait la surveillance
un truc tout bête aussi euh on prend un
email euh
on on rédige un brouillon oui et on
envoie jamais le mail bon genre genre le
batlan voilà bon donc je rédige mon
brouillon je suis à Genève et je me dis
mon contact à Paris euh il va prendre la
même adresse mail il va lire le bouillon
le le mail ne sera pas parti et donc il
y a une boîte qui ouvre à Genève une
boîte qui ouvre à Paris et tout le temps
au bout d'un moment les moteurs qui
travaillent sur les emails et cetera
vont dire attends le il y a un problème
et ça remonte voilà tout ça donc le le
meilleur moyen de pas de pas avoir
d'ennui c'est d'avoir un comportement
normal bon de pas être être de de
respecter le code de la route de
respecter d'avoir un comportement normal
raconte-moi quand tu t'es fait tamponner
par X ou Y
pas je j'ai pas été euh il m'aurait
attrapé bien je serais pas là pour en
parler
euh mais bon oui il y a eu des j'ai eu
de la chance on va dire et après il y a
eu des contrecoups et où les discussions
étaient chaudes ouais mais voilà par qui
comment quand on travaille sur ce qui
s'est passé en Israël euh avant le 7
octobre et les conséquences et cetera
il y a des discussions tendues à un
moment qu'on peut avoir avec des membres
soit du shunbet soit d'ancien du mossade
soit voilà il y a des discussions
forcément il y a des moments où on
partage pas les mêmes opinions
euh après les faits sont
là donc moi ce que j'espère c'est qu'il
y aura une commission d'enquête
officielle et je suis pas le seul à
l'espérer il y a énormément d'anciens
des services israéli netaniaou là oui
oui oui mais pas il faut voir faudrait
qu'on puisse en parler en détail mais
mais
i c'est ouvert alors alors pas
diffamation ce qui arrivé s C cubiques
ok pas de
problème si on
regarde l'histoire de de ce qui s'est
passé avec la bande de Gazin mais il fa
il faudrait que je reparte d'un peu plus
loin prenons voilà prenons je suis
l'analyste je vous livre
les éléments et puis technicien de
terrain je suis l'analyste voilà et mais
le but du jeu c'est que les gens qui
peuvent avoir qui nous regardent et qui
peuvent avoir une opinion très tranchée
c'est blanc ou noir voilà palestinien
tu parles des GSE là non non on va on va
on va leur faire comprendre un peu que
il y a c'est beaucoup de zones grises
bon qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on va on
va essayer de remonter de voir ce qui
peut être utile dans la compréhension de
de ce qui s'est passé d'abord Israël n
pas le premier pays juif qui a été créé
au 20e siècle le premier État juif état
pour les Juifs d'accord ça a été créé
par Staline ça s'appelle le birau
Bidjan ça a été créé par Staline en 1934
en 1934 il a dit à sa populationcei j'ai
rien contre vous je vous donne un état
le birau Bidjan qui est beaucoup plus
grand qu'Israël qui a des ressources
naturelles
et vous faites ce que vous voulez vous
parle yed si vous voulez vous avez votre
toutes les caractéristiques d' ét clim
pourri alors c'est pas un climat pourri
c'est un climat qui est à peu près celui
qu'on a dans les Laurentide au Canada
donc ça serait mauvais ça serait méchant
pour les Canadiens de dire ça et donc
l'objectif de base c'est d'avoir à peu
près un million TR de personnes au
départ au démarrage he ce qui est bon
Albert Einstein soutient
l'initiative à cette époque là c'est
déjà une sommité c'est c'est une
rockstar Einstein il est riche il va il
va soutenir ce sur ses denniers
personnels notamment un orphelina avec
qu'il était payé en orord je savais pas
mais bon
euh et donc ça prend vie de ce côté-là
on est en 34 en 35 côté Moyen-Orient euh
herzel qui lui a fait sa courte vie a
passé sa court viille a essayé de de
convaincre qu'il fallait créer un État
juif en Palestine
euh meurt il meurt en
35 on
continue on
arrive en 38 39 le pape
Pidou se rend compte que le monde change
beaucoup à cause de la poussée
hitlerienne que ça menace que Hitler
menace aussi l'Église catholique et
cetera et qu'il y a des réfugiés partout
et il demande à un cardinal le cardinal
Montini de créer un service de
renseignement ce service de
renseignement moderne pour le Vatican
parce qu'il y a toujours eu un peu des
espions du Vatican mais moderne pour le
Vatican il est chargé notamment de gérer
le problème des réfugiés et il va être
en contact avec le grand Rabin de
Jérusalem Isaac Herzog qui est un parent
d'Isaac Herzog le président d'Israël
aujourd'hui ça me fait penser à un film
non mais et et et les lettres qui
s'échangent sont poignante on voit d'un
côté le désespoir d'un grand Rabin qui
appelle au secours PID et qui demande un
entretien il aura pas l'entretien direct
avec Pidou parce qu'il a peur que Hitler
soit choqué de ça mais par contre il va
il va avoir l'entretien avec son
ministre des Affaires étrangères et avec
le service de renseignement des vaticans
et ça va très bien marcher ils vont
faire des chos ensemble qui vont
permettre de sauver beaucoup de
gens mais ça marche parce
que le Vatican identifie le grand Rabin
de Jérusalem comme étant le représentant
de la communauté
juive aujourd'hui on a un problème c'est
qu'il y a une communauté juive qui est
multi
elle c'est une mosaïque elle est
multiple on prend un exemple de et c'est
important pour ce qui s'est passé dans
la
catégorie extrême de ce côté-là on a les
né Touré
cararta le patron le Rabin Dovid veis
les nourcarta ils sont antisionistes
c'est des juifs des rabins orthodoxes
d'accord antisionistes ça veut dire quoi
antisioniste ça veut dire que et il le
dit il dit je veux la destruction
d'Israël après il rajoute mais je veux
pas qu'on tue les Juifs alors je sais
pas comment il fait pour détruire Israël
sans tuer les Juifs mais c'est quelqu'un
qu'on a vu en Iran avec des néonazis
avec des négationnistes invité par
amadinejja dans 2006 on l'a vu aussi à
Londres avec une des patronnes des
néonazis
Lonienne avant le le le le c'était pas
le 18 c'était en juin à l'ONU on l'a vu
en 2023 j donc avant les événements on
l'a vu discuter avec le président
iranien bon donc c'est quelqu'un qui a
une conception très personnelle et son
groupe c'est une secte he les n
tourcarta c'est une secte maintenant
cette secte là elle dérange aujourd'hui
elle dérange quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé avant on pouvait dire bon on les
met de côté c'est c'est un peu des vieux
fous allez on tire le rideau et puis on
les laisse après ce qui s'est passé
c'est c'est un problème pour moi c'est
un problème je en tant qu'analyste
savoir que ces gens-là ont des moyens
c'est une secte euh qui peut qui a des
yeux et des oreilles et qui peut
renseigner
éventuellement un ennemi potentiel c'est
un problème pourquoi alors ennemi Israël
on en a besoin mais et Israël on en a
besoin de l'Israël de 48 on va venir en
dehors des néourcartia il y a les
satmars une autre catégorie très
orthodoxe aussi très très très fermés
d'accord euh et petit à petit comme ça
on descend on descend et on a on a les
les Juifs progressistes les Juifs plus
modernes qui veulent c'est plus du tout
le même monde et on a les Juifs
messianiques on a les Juifs messianiques
on a de tout mais c'est plus du tout le
même monde quand on va aujourd'hui à
téavive le samedi à la viive il y a de
la vie il y a pas de
problèmeire bon quand on va à 30 km à à
à betchemch à nebark c'est des des
villes orthodoxes c'est plus du tout la
même chose et Jérusalem encore c'est pas
la même chose moi j'étais à measharim
après les événements masharim c'est
ultra orthodoxe d'accord euh bah il y
avait de la vie chez eux alors que tout
le reste de Jérusalem c'était mort parce
que ça les gênait pas il y avait des
drapeaux palestiniens dans masharim il y
avait des des des taxes sur les murs les
zionistes
dehors ils sont
antisioniste donc dans un même pays on a
maintenant une différence religieuse qui
est très forte et qui pose un problème
parce que ça pose un poids politique
c'est des soutiens de l'extrême droite
les colons qu'on voit de temps en temps
à la télé les colons ils obéissent plus
à l'armée ils obéissent au Rabin à leur
Rabin ce qui s'est passé ce matin où il
y a de jours un ministre qui sort un
pétard parce qu'il y avait des colos en
face qui étaient qui voulaient
l'attraper tu as pas vu ça c'est c'est
alors j'ai pas vu mais c'est c'est un
des parce que j'étais dans le train mais
c'est un des problèmes qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est que ces colons là
c'est ingérable je ve dire c'est mais je
reviens sur mon histoire on était avec
le Vatican et ce grand Rabin et donc ils
arrivent à sauver des vies euh et tout
ça pour vous dire que en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que à partir du moment
où on identifie un interlocuteur qui
donne une solution qu'on arrive à monter
quelque chose de fort euh c'est efficace
à côté de ça le Vatican il était noyé de
demande il avait des trucs farfelus il
fallait créer des états Juifs en
Amérique latine et tout le barda qui
truc ilils ont laissé tomber rapidement
euh l'ironie du sort c'est que le
cardinal Montini que je dont je parlais
tout à l'heure c'est devenu Paul 6 c'est
le pape Paul 6 et ce pauvre Paul VI à la
fin de la guerre on lui dit bah voilà il
a été un super agent soyons clair il a
aidé la CIA il aé
euh l'esoe de l'époque euh qui est
devenu la CIA et
euh à la fin on lui dit bah voilà
euh maintenant on adopte la doctrine
Truman on fait la chasse aux
communistes et il faut permettre au
nazis de [__] le camp et lui il avait
il était là pour donner des coups de
tampon sur des sur des documents des
réfugiés il a c'est vrai que le Vatican
a aidé les nazis à sortir et dans l'eau
il y en avait un qu'on connaît bien euh
euh fusé non mais qui était euh euh le
Lyonnais comment Claus Barbie closeus
Barb en fait a tout de suite à la fin de
la guerre il se fait attraper par les
Américains les Américains l'intègrent
dans la CIA il avait un salaire de 1700
dollars par mois et il a pu quitter pour
la Bolivie où il est devenu un baron de
la drogue et il a travaillé après on
savait parfaitement où il était Barber
et tout ça tout ça pour vous dire que
dans l'histoire c'est pas blanc bleu on
est tout le temps dans la dans une zone
opaque voilà et donc je continue mon
histoire en 48 évidemment benouron crée
Israël en 48 il fait une déclaration
d'indépendance dans cette déclaration
d'indépendance il est écrit noir sur
blanc que dans l'état d'Israël l'homme
et la femme ont les mêmes droits il y a
une égalité de l'homme et de la
femme
benouron ne fait pas de
Constitution il ne bétonne pas les
institutions pourquoi parce que c'est un
pays naissant et que ça arrive de
partout quand il démarre il y a 800000
personne c'est tout petit d'accord mais
il dit si je commence à mettre des
carcans et il ne fait pas de
Constitution il se dit je fais une
déclaration la Constitution verra plus
tard aujourd'hui Israël n'a toujours pas
de constitution et c'est un
problème un avocat comme Eliad schraga a
proposé déjà des des des
constitutions ça fait pas la une de la
presse ça devrait c'est un élément
majeur pour Israël d'avoir une
constitution de protéger les
institutions notamment judiciaire de
toute réforme qui pourrait amener à une
dictature voilà donc ça c'est un élément
majeur dont on a besoin aujourd'hui si
on veut construire demain il faut
ça et benouron époque il a il a
euh le souci de faire un état laïque
Israël qui démarre c'est un État laïque
c'est les kibousim c'est c'est les gens
qui partagent che des j'allais dire
c'est des c'est des soci c'est c'est
quand même il y a la mouvance communiste
entre Guillet c'est pas du communisme
dur mais mais il y a le partage
communautaire qu'on peut retrouver dans
l'idéologie et il a à faire beaucoup à
des gens de de gauche et des survivants
donc des survivants qui sont pas
attachés au matériel le propre des
survivants des camps et tout ça c'est un
détachement total du matériel c'est et
donc la volonté de construire quoi qu'il
arrive ils ont peur de rien bon et donc
il part sur une société
laïque qui absorbe du
monde avec l'égalité
hommees-femme petit à petit ça
grandit on arrive à 2 millions de
personnes dans les années 60 en dans les
années 80 on se rend compte que le poids
de l'État en Israël est très important
et que ça pose un problème économique on
va réduire le poids de
l'État on arrive en
80 les accords d'Oslo je sais plus c'est
95 ou j'ai plus la date exact mais les
accords d'Oslo parlons-en parce que ça
c'est c'est quelque chose de majeur
aussi dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui Clinton demande à Aak
Rabin de signer les accord d'Oslo avec S
Arafat Clinton sa femme ou lui lui il
est président il est président mais en
chute libre et il se dit je vais me
rattraper en faisant un coup à
l'étranger ma popularité s'effondre je
dire Macron à côté c'est
voilà avant ou après la T lutte alors je
me souviens plus exactement mais bon ça
s'effondre bon en face de lui il a AC
Rabine Isac Rabine c'était un un homme
qui était assez fort intellectement et
physiquement mais à cette époque là il
commence
la journée en vidant une bouteille de
whisky et on peut pas lui parler tant
qu'il a pas terminé IAC Rabine à ce
moment-là il est atteint d'alcoolisme il
est fatigué et c'est un homme fatigué
qui va se présenter aux accords d'Oslo
en face de lui il y a Yasser Arafat qui
lui aussi est un peu controversé lui il
a aussi des il a Yasser Arafat c'était
une pharmacie ambulante il faisait de
l'automédication donc c'est pas étonnant
s'il s'est empoisonné au bout d'un
moment mais mais il end attends attends
il s'est empoisonné tout seul on sait
pas mais il est capable Yasser Arafat il
trimballait un nombre de médicaments
mais et et tu tu connais euh clamar un
peu l'hôpital là oui tu le connais oui
mais alors on on on on ira dans le
détail s'il faut mais c'est pas c'est te
fasse un réflexe de Laurence tout de
suite ou c'est pas essentiel c'est pas
essentiel et donc voilà le trio qu'on a
au bout rien trouvé dans ces petites
affaires et et les deux que ça soit y
arfat etak Rabin disent mais cet accord
d'Oslo ça n'ira nulle part c'est pas bon
c'est pas équilibré ça Clinton dit ok
mais moi j'en ai besoin on signe voilà
quand quand il sig ils ont pas trouvé
des trucs un peu bizarres sur les
affaires de Arafat non non non non non
il y a eu c'est sa femme qui a voulu qu'
a une enquête pour l'empoisonnement et
cetera mais bon sa femme elle est partie
avec les millions et elle a elle a été
inculpée quand ils veulent signer les
les Clinton SIG président des États-Unis
IAC Rabin Premier ministre ok Arafat
voit le président des palestinien il dit
non mais je suis pas président des
palestinens je suis président de l'OLP
c'est pas la même chose et donc il
président de l'OLP et donc c'est vrai
que les Palestiniens n'ont pas eu un
représentant qui les représentait qui a
signé pour eux il y a eu le président de
l'OLP mais c'est pas les palestines
et ça le Hamas s'en sert dans son
discours en disant bah nous les accords
d'Oslo voilà c'est pas nous euh et et là
c'est c'est un point
sensible après les accords d'Oslo ils
ont été contestés en Israël aussi enfin
bon ça et on connaît l'histoireine se
fait
tuer par qui d'ailleurs par un par un
membre de la des colons de de l'extrême
droite et euh et pour la petite histoire
au moinszel où vous avez les différentes
tombes des des des des présidents et des
premiers ministres Isac Rabine il a une
tombe un peu à part qui est plus grande
que les autres en reconnaissance parce
que c'est quand même le seul qui s'est
fait tuer
et
euh ça continue on avance dans le temps
en
2004 moi j'ai le document et je l'ai
donné ça fait partie de mon procès
verbal Yasser Arafat prévient
que le financement du
Hamas est très dangereux notamment parce
qu'il va se faire par des
ONG que l'argent est en train d'être de
d'arriver vers le Hamas via des ONG et
l'argent du Hamas c'était qui alors en
2004 j'ai pas pu je suis pas remonté à
cette époque-là par contre en
2012 l'argent il arrive par le Qatar et
avant 2004 tu as pas une petite idée
d'où il
venait j'ai pas j'ai c'est pas une
question d'avoir une idée surtout pour
ça il faut avoir non non ilut moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce qui est arrivé
c'est suffisamment grave pour pas faire
des des suppositions en 2012 ce qui est
sûr c'est que le Qatar s'intéresse à la
bande de Gaza altani vient en 2012 il
fait une visite ce qui est assez rare
quand même c'est je crois que c'est un
des
rares représentants du monde arabe qui
est venu dans la bande de Gaza et on
décide de la
reconstruction de la uction de Gaza Gaza
avant les événements c'était une partie
du monde arabe qui était très correcte
he il y avait correct dans quel sens en
terme des bons bâtiments il y avait des
des restaurants rooftop il y avait des
salles de gym il y avait des il y avait
du chocolat alors le chocolat j'en sais
rien mais il y avait des belles allées
il y avait une belle allée il y avait
une belle promenade il y avit combien de
calories par personne sur place à
l'époque non non il y avait pas non non
Gaza était parfaitement dans les
standards du
Moyen-Orient parce que depuis
2012 l'argent arrivait mais pour que
l'argent arrive et ça fait partie des
documents qui ont été versés c'est le
Qatar qui les a
versé alors on me dit mais voilà le
Qatar il versait l'argent pour que a la
paix sociale dans Gaza il payit les
salaire il pay les salair fonctionnaire
la paix sociale la première erreur
l'argent est versé en cash en billet de
banque en dollars par billet de 100
d'accord donc c'est pas traçable or
l'économie de la bande de Gaza elle est
en chéquel elle est pas en
dollar l'économie d'Israël c'est du
chquel donc on pouvait transférer
l'argent en dollar à la banque centrale
d'Israël laquelle faisait le transfert
des chqueles en cash il faut du cash il
y a pas de problème on peut faire des
virements aussi il y a des banques à
Gazin mais s'il faut du cash on fait du
cash mais on fait du
chquel mais là le choix de faire un
financement en dollars et en billets de
banque il est
meurtrier parce que ça va permettre au
Hamas d'abord de faire des gains sur le
dos de la population en faisant des
gains de change et en plus d'acheter des
armes et de financer ces
tunnels là où c'est intérêt
et ça vous pouvez le vérifier je suis
sûr que nos internautes qui sont
derrière l'écran vont se faire un
plaisir de tapoter vous avez une société
qui est sous sanction
américaine depuis bien avant les
événements qui s'appelle trend g trend
TR g elle est côté à
istanou on tapote et on regarde le
graphique du cours de l'action avant
après le 7 octobre
cette
société moi je pense et c'est mon
opinion elle elle a participé à la
construction des tunnels c'est mon
opinion non mais ton opinion tu te les
fait comment ton opinion tu as des
sources tu as des yeux sur place parce
que là là quand tu me dis ça alors elle
est réputé si elle est dans la
construction être réputé de ça veut rien
dire non plus bah elle est sous sanction
alors elle a été mise sous sanction pour
sa Proxim je me fais l'avocat du diable
voilà donc les autorités américaines on
jugéation
cette société est sous sanction
américaine bien qu'elle soit côté et
qu'elle continue à être côté et elle est
dans la construc dans le secteur de la
construction elle est réputée avoir un
lien avec le Hamas qui qui donne cette
réputation les États-Unis bon et qui aux
États-Unis la
justice le fait est que quand on
construit un réseau de tunnel qui est
aussi important que le métro parisien
plus étroit mais aussi important en
terme de kilomètrre d'accord ça se voit
ça se
sait le
tunnel c'est pas pour transporter des
marchandises ou pas pour des problèmes
humanitaires c'est une arme par
destination le tunnel le but du jeu
c'est d'aller attaquer le
voisin et donc ça se voit en 2014 il y a
des membres de l'unité 8200 qui écrivent
à l'époque à netanahù et qui se disent
moi je je veux plus faire la
surveillance qu'on fait sur la bande de
Gaza parce qu'elle est trop extrême
et donc ils se font virer d'ailleurs il
y en a une quarantaine qui se font virer
bon donc la surveillance elle est bien
là mais extrême en quel sens il trouve
que c'est tellement intrusif que ça les
choque sur le plan de l'éthique en terme
de cheval de TR de zone sur place de
caméas dans les tunnels tout mais tout
la bande de Gaza c'est l'endroit
peut-être le plus surveillé du
monde bon c'est pas l'Élysée non donc
donc la preuve en est donc que ces gens
en 2014 écrivent cette lettre c'est dans
les journaux israéliens euh et
euh le financement continue on arrive en
2018 le procureur mandelblit
euh s'inquiète du financement de la
bande de Gaza qui prend des proportions
il il fait une réunion avec les
différents
services résultat des courses netanahou
utilise son autorité pour dire moi je
suis Premier ministre on continue et ça
fait comme
ça les documents que j'ai amené avec un
collègue de la CIA et avec la police
jordanienne montre que à un moment le
Qatar fait un virement de 50 millions de
dollars vers une ONG qui a son compte
bancaire chez
HSBC HSBC la compliance ssbc refuse elle
motive en disant c'est du financement du
as c'est du financement du terrorisme on
n' veut
pas résultat des courses le Hamas fait
un document et le Hamas le Qatar fait un
document ce qui est bien avec la la la
la Banque centrale du Qatar c'est
qu'elle documente tout ce qu'elle fait
parce qu'ils ont peur de se faire taper
sur les doigts elle fait son document
pour dire on va livrer du cash et on le
donne à
naniao
voilà donc moi je je ce que je demande
avec ces documents là c'est une
enquête qui c'est qui t'a diligenté pour
faire ça alors alors c'est ça a fait
l'objet d'un documentaire de la raille
euh la journaliste c'est Julia Bosetti
donc Laar c'est une télévision publique
italienne le documentaire il doit faire
à peu près 40
minutes dans ce documentaire
j'interviens mais je suis pas seul à mes
côtés on voit à l'écran quelqu'un comme
oui Levi 35 ans de
mossade une star en matière de
financement du terrorisme il a fait son
doctorat sur le lancement du Hamas et
quand il en parle je veux dire il
connaît c'est le Hamas il avait mais
c'est des centaines et des centaines de
sociétés à sa disposition même encore
aujourd'hui le Hamas c'est une énorme
organisation criminelle à la base ça
part petit politique mais au fur et à
mesure que ça grossit ça devient une
pieuvre c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre les gens disent mais il était
encarté au Hamas et cetera les pauvres
Palestiniens qui sont dans la bande de
Gaza n'ont jamais eu le
choix que de que de payer leur dim ou
amass pour pour tout vous ouvrez un
magasin faut payer c'est comme c'est
c'est du raquette tout le temps et donc
et et le Yaya sinoir qui a été
tué c'était quelqu'un qui était
extrêmement cruel quand il quand il
arrêtait des Palestiniens il en a mis en
prison il en a torturé il en a tué je
veux dire ce gars-là n'avait aucune
limite le t qu'on a eu avec yayassinoir
c'est de le
tuer on voit bien dans la vidéo que
quand il est quand on quand il l'attrape
il a pas de gilet il explosif euh il est
fatigué on aurait pu l'avoir vivant et
ça c tu parles tu parles de celui qui
était encore qui avait pas mangé depuis
48 ou 72 he et qui s'est fait désinguer
par un drone qui lui a fait coucou avant
il lui manquait un bras c'est lui alors
il s'est pris une balle dans la tête
ouis euh mais on donc il a été tiré à
à distance
courte on dit à boutortant ouis il y
avait la marque du canon ou pas
non mais il l'a pris bien là quand même
et le ce qui est extrêmement dommage
dans c'est yir on l'aurait eu vivant il
s'était fait un Garau avec un un câble
de de lampe c'est ça un fil électrique
non non je crois pas mais on on l'aurait
eu vivant on l'aurait eu vivant on
pouvait faire un procès il aurait
expliqué comment il se
finançait il on l'aurait eu vivant mais
on aurait l'équivalent du procès Eichman
imaginez quand on attrape le Mossad
attrape Eichman que Eichman meurt ça
n'avait plus aucune valeur d'accord
Eichman on lui a donné un procès avec un
avocat qui était une des stars du
barreau
allemand on aurait pu faire la même
chose avec sinoir ça aurait eu une
incidence énorme on aurait puvite faire
encore un martyre ah bah oui parce que
là pour les Palestiniens bah bon malgré
le fait que ça soit quelqu'un qui
détestait sinoir il était pas tellement
aimé chez lui quand même ils en avaient
peur en fait
euh donc c'était une belle
crapule mais on aurait quand même pu lui
faire un procès il aurait pu s'expliquer
il aurait pu dire pourquoi il aurait pu
donner son financement et dire comment
il en est arrivé là voilà pour il est
considéré comme un un un éminent
résistant bah parce que quand on
bombarde une population la la bande de
Gaza c'est peut-être aujourd'hui
l'endroit de la planète qui est le plus
bombardé en en en
kilotonne bon
euh ça fait un peu de pollution dans les
sols alors on va en parler on va en
parler on va en parler
euh pourquoi on pense pas à à ne à ne
pas à éviter de faire des martyres qui
pourrai être utilisés contre que ce soit
dans un sens dans peut-être aussi le
fait de pourquoi on a tué an nué Agier
alors qu'on était en train de négocier
la sortie des otages quand il a été tué
alors qu'on aurait pu choper plus tard
ça c'était pas c'était pas critique de
le choper à ce moment-là
euh et lui aussi il avait des choses à
raconter est-ce qu'on a vraiment envie
d'arrêter cette guerre alors
euh la grande majorité des des
Israéliens notamment les laïques oui ça
c'est clair on voit le milieu orthodoxe
récemment il y a une centaine de rabins
qui ont signé une lettre qui se sont
opposés à la libération des otages bon
euh bah oui mais c'est des rabins
orthodoxes hein c'est la partie
orthodoxe ultraorthodoxe c'est la partie
c'est c'est les c'est les rabins qui
sont au-dessus des colons voà c'est la
doctrine Hannibale c'est c'est c'est des
gens qui n'ont pas le même concept
d'Israël qui ne veulent pas de l'Israël
laïque faut dire ce qu' est ils veulent
un Israël il veulent ils veulent le
talmou et l'application du talmou ou
toutes les femmes avec les cous doivent
être couverts avec les genoux couverts
avec les perruques et les machins c'est
c'est c'est une autre c'est une autre
époque avec mais la déclaration encore
une fois d'indépendance d'Israël
l'égalité de l'homme et de la
femme or aujourd'hui la femme dans la
vie publique israélienne elle est plus
nulle part B dans la vie privée dans la
vie privée israélienne qu'elles ont le
pouvoir hein non malheureusement quand
on voit le classement d'Israël de de le
il y a un classement CDE sur la
l'égalité homm-femme ça ça s'effondre et
c'est donc c'est tout ça est très
dommageable qui ve nous on a besoin ENIT
on a besoin d' État israélien parce que
on a les mêmes ennemis en ce sens que on
a un problème avec les Frères musulmans
et on a un problème aussi avec Poutine
bon il se trouve que Isra problème avec
l'Iran aussi non alors l'Iran on va en
parler oui
c'est oui on en parle tout de suite
après on parlera de la reconstruction de
la bande de Gaza l'Iran tu parles de la
la petite planche où il y a les futurs
appartements en bord de bord de mer là
non c'est ça la reconstruction non non
non d'accord l'Iran pourquoi le Grand
Israël on fait une petite digression ou
pas du tout alors soit on parle d'israël
encore ou je parle de l'Iran mais c'est
comme tu veux mais fini sur Israël avec
alors le aujourd'hui la bande de Gaza
qu'est-ce qu'on a détru à 70 % il y a
plus d'éces il y a les hôpitaux
impraticables et cetera très sévèrement
détruit on parle de 40 millions de
tonnes de débris ce qui fait que ces
débris là si on doit les déplacer pour
pouvoir reconstruire il faut un espace
d' à peu près 400 hectares or ces 400
hectares on ne les a pas on fait une île
alors on les a pas en Égypte on les a
pas en Israël C ces débris là ont été
touchés par des missiles guidés dans des
missile guidé il y a du brylium entre
autres qui est un métal très nocif très
cancér 400 400 combien non ah je sais
mais globalement de toute façon quand on
bombarde avec les missiles d'aujourd'hui
c'est pas très B hein donc il y a un
problème de contamination il y a un
problème même pour l'armée
israélienne ces débris là sont
relativement toxique un peu comme les
mêmes en Ukraine non on avait le même
problème en Irak surtout tu parles de
l'uranium appouvri non alors pas mais
l'IRAC il y a pas que l'uranium imp
prenons le cas de du fils Biden beau
Biden il a fait quelques mois en Irak 3
ans après il est mort d'un cancer du
cerveau parce qu'il a respiré les les la
toxicité de été établi oui oui oui tout
à fait oui oui et son père d'ailleurs l'
l' a c'est grâce à ça que les les
vétérans ont un traitement euh et il y
en a un
paquet les vétérans d'irac ont un
traitement particulier sur ces ces
problématiques là on reviens sur les 40
millions tonnes de débris donc ces
débris là sont problématiques personne
n'en veut qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on
peut les sortir et construire une piste
d'aéroport qu'on prend sur la mer
on met les débris dans
l'eau évidemment ça va polluer un peu
mais lot va faire en sorte que bon voilà
on n pas tellement le choix on peut
aussi prendre ses débris et aller
construire un port en eau
profonde les deux infrastructures vont
faciliter la reconstruction de
Gaza pour pouvoir les soulever et les
sortir là on peut utiliser des
hélicoptères ÉIS 26 qui soulève jusqu'à
20 tonnes la Jordanie sur le papier en a
4 je sais pas s'ils sont fonctionnels
parce que c'est des c'est c'est des du
matériel russe et il faut avoir les
pièces détachées les pilotes et tout et
cetera mais le mi26 c'est le seul
appareil qui soulève 20 tonnes euh et
donc ça peut être utile pour la
reconstruction parce qu'il s'agit
d'aller chercher des débris euh dans
Gaza et d'aller les porter juste à côté
dans la mer je ça va on va pas loin et
on va comme ça construire une jetée avec
la jetée deviendra un port la jetée
deviendra une piste
d'atterrissage et il faut qu'il y ait
des revenus
dans la bande de Gaza qui soit pas les
revenus du Qatar il se trouve que le 18
juin
2023 donc avant les événements du 7
octobre
netaniaahou a signé l'accord pour le
champ de gaz Gaza marine qui se trouve à
35 km de
Gaza ça faisait 20 ans qu'il travaillait
là-dessus plus de 20 ans que différentes
administrations palestiniennes et
israéliennes travaillaient là-dessus et
donc il y a un champ de gaz qui permet
de dégager on estime que les cashfow que
ça peut dégager c'est à peu près de
l'ordre de 600 millions de dollars par
an sur combien de temps le temps de vie
de ce champ de gaz on l'espère le plus
long possible parce que si c'est ça qui
doit financer ça financera pas la
reconstruction ça financera la
l'administration Gazaoui he s'il y en a
une bon mais ça peut changer la donne
tout ça peut permettre de passer d'un
état où on est archidépendant du Qatar
lequel passe l'argent en arrosant côté
israélien à un état qui peut
vivre
indépendamment donc c'est pas rien comme
solution j'en vois pas d'autrre
personnellement
bon quand on me dit on va faire deux
états un État palestinien un état
israélien deux États qui vont être comme
des frères ennemis tout le temps bon moi
je sais pas comment on
fait quand on va à
pizzgazé qui est en dans le district de
Jérusalem à l'opposé du Mont herzel il y
a un tram qui va du Mont voisel à à
pisgazzé pisgazzé c'est c'est ça a été
il y a longtemps il y a dans les années
80 considéré comme une colonie
aujourd'hui c'est totalement inéré il y
a des Arabes et le palier sur le même
palier il y a des familles juifes c'est
et ça vit bien je c'est le vivre
ensemble
euh quand va à Acre ce qu'on connaît
sous le nom de Saint-Jean d'Acre qui est
plus au nord sur la côte euh il y a
jamais eu de problème même pendant les
événements là même quand Israël est allé
au
Liban au niveau de Hare il y a quasiment
rien eu et il y a au moins 30 % de la
population d'AC qui est
arabe donc le vivre ensemble existe
bien la solution et et c'est des propos
que je je rapporte qui avec j'ai discuté
avec des des officiers israéliens avec
des responsables israéliens la solution
c'est plus on va faire le vivre ensemble
plutôt que deux pays qui vont être en
chien de faillance et et on ne saura
comment on fait pour séparer les routes
le pays qu'on va créer d'abord j'ai
montré qu'avec le birau Bidjan créer un
pays hein le birau Bidjan c'est kutchev
qui abandonne en 53 il dit ok on arrête
tout euh alors qu'il y avait il y avait
il y avait un soutien aux États-Unis il
y avait un truc qui s'appelait l'AMB
Bidjan aux États-Unis qui permettait
d'aller router des des fond encore
là-bas bon et ils ont arrêté en 53 parce
que Israël avait pris le dessus et puis
c'était fini le bureau Bidjan c'est bon
et donc créer un pays c'est créer une
banque centrale créer une monnaie créer
un drapeau créer une armée
peut-être créer une
économie mais comment l'Autorité
palestinienne N a pas la
volonté à aucun moment ils ont présenté
un plan pour la la création d'un
pays donc on peut dire oui on veut créer
un pays ok ben chomi montre-moi le bébé
comment on fait moi sur place je vois
quoi je vois la terre c'est de la
caillass c'est du calcaire il fait chaud
à crever l'été il y a rien qui pousse
alors il y a rien qui pousse il y a un
truc que j'ai trouvé merveilleux et qui
est quand même une inspiration poétique
si je peux avoir un moment de poésie à
Jérusalem il y a un truc exceptionnel
c'est que quoi qu'il il arrive il peut y
avoir les guerres de tout ce qu'on veut
quoi qu'il arrive à Jérusalem il y a des
tulipes sauvages qui poussent de nulle
part et il y a des champs de tulipes
sauvage c'est d'une merveille de voir ça
ça me fait penser à la phrase de nerouda
vous pouvez piétiner le les fleurs vous
n'arrêterez pas le printemps et ben ça
c'est le message d'espoir de la soirée
vous n'arrêterez pas le printemps vous
n'arrêterez pas le fait que le vivre
ensemble existe qu'on peut parfaitement
encore aujourd'hui vivre ensemble entre
les Israéliens et les Arabes et que
c'est beaucoup plus réaliste d'aller sur
cette voie là parce que aujourd'hui on a
un problème parce que les Palestiniens
n'ont pas le même statut que les
Israéliens il y a CIN statuts
administratifs différents pour les
Palestiniens d'accord donc on peut en
avoir qu'un
seul un enfant palestinien qui a 12 ans
qui balance un caillou qui se fait
arrêter parce qu'il a fait une bêtise
contre l'armée israélienne il passe
devant un tribunal militaire à 12 ans un
tribunal militaire où il aura en face
que des Israéliens qui parlent l'hébreux
alors que lui il parle l'arabe et s'il a
un avocat c'est un avocat
arabe si c'est un Israélien il faut
attendre qu'il ait 14 ans pour qu'il
soit jugé pourquoi pourquoi cette
différence il y a pas de raison le vivre
ensemble c'est ça aussi c'est accepter
de dire ok on il y a il y a un problème
j'aime pas le Moot part tête parce que
ça a été inventé par les les Anglais en
Afrique du Sud la partide et et c'est
pas aussi profond que la partide mais
euh il y a une une telle différenciation
administrative dans le traitement des
gens que on peut pas s'en sortir prenons
le cas des prisonniers qui a aujourd'hui
euh encore retenu et qui dont une partie
va être libérée euh euh ces gens-là
n'ont pas d'avocat et n'ont aucun droit
à avoir un avocat donc il y a 10000
personnes dont 300 enfants là-dedans euh
qui on euh ils ont été arrêtés ils sont
pas jugés et on sait pas pour combien de
temps ils sont là c'est c'est c'est pas
du travail ça est-ce que tu connais le
principe de l'arithmétique de la
rébellion non je t' pas particulièrement
non imagine-toi on doit tuer un
terroriste
oui c'est toi qui est responsable des
opérations extérieures et moi je te dis
pépé Pépé le méchant il est là il est à
l'anniversaire de son cousin bon l'
anniversaire du cousin il y a le voisin
il y a le neveu il y a la
tante on tue le terroriste on tue tout
le
monde la famille
voit c'est cadavres ouais c'est l'arme
et donc ça fait des gens qui vont aller
se rebeller plus tard bien sûr et ça va
t'en faire 10 pour un est-ce que tu
penses que là on a dépassé le seuil de
va tellement y avoir de rébellion mais
on a fait pire que ça parce que avec on
n pas parlé deunur la la l'entité de
l'ONU qui gérait le la bande de Gaza
notamment et la question palestinienne
dans l'ONU bon
euh il av quelques combattants du Hamas
dedans non alors mais c'est ce que j'ai
dit pour pouvoir travailler dans Gaza il
fallait être encarté c'est comme un
parti politique he donc bon c'est comme
un parti politique th horrible c'est
vrai c'est en France tu parles voilà on
veut du boulot faut avoir la carte voilà
tu veux un appartement voilà on fait du
social d'accord le problème c'est que
les écoles même pour les petits je parle
des écoles primaires on savait déjà que
l'enseignement dans les écoles primaires
euh était un enseignement de haine j'ai
vu moi des dessins animés pour enfants
où le Juif c'est la caricature du Juif
comme dans les les films qu'on montrait
la période
hitlerrienne et les enfants étit en
uniforme on leur donne des jouets et on
leur dit voilà tu fais comme ça tu fais
comme ça on leur donne un entraînement
militaire on les on leur lave le cerveau
en leur disant mais ton ennemi c'est le
juif et ça l'unra le
voit et elle intervient pas et et je
veux dire nous en Occident on voit aussi
et on na rien fait donc c'est là c'est
un problème collectif c'est pas
seulement un problème israélien c'est un
problème collectif on a laissé faire ça
on a laissé moi j'ai j'ai les vidéos des
entraînements des camp d'entraînement
d'enfants avec des vraies armes bon euh
jusqu'à quel âge oh ils sont jeunes hein
ils ont il y en a qui ont là-dedans qui
ont 13 ans pas plus hein donc à partir
du moment où le gosse il est
complètement dooctriné que depuis le
petit depuis le tout petit on lui dit
euh tu dois tuer du Juif bah le 7
octobre il tue du Juif
hein alors qu'au départ on lui demande
de prendre des otages et que ça dégénère
bah oui parce que l'endentrinement il
est tel que voilà donc euh aussi quand
quand lunura elle voit bien les tunnels
elle le sait qu'il y a des tunnels
devant chez elle ah bah on peut pas un
réseau pareil on peut pas le tout le
monde le voit je veux dire c'est bon et
et
et on est tous responsabl parce que
personne n'a rien fait aujourd'hui on
dit B l'UNA bon il y a ceux qui disent
il faut l'éliminer
ok mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait qui la
remplace comment on la remplace donc on
peut changer le
nom on ne doit plus laisser l'ONU s'en
occuper bon en fait le problème de
l'unra c'est qu'il faut que les gens qui
soient dedans ils aient des compétences
particulières et les compétences c'est
des compétences policières pour pouvoir
détecter le financement criminel pour
pouvoir détecter l'usage le blanchiment
d'argent s'il y en a on ne peut pas
créer une
organisation crime organisé ou
terroriste sans financement sans circuit
de financement et donc il faut que la
nouvelle entité elle est en son sein
beaucoup plus dans anciens policiers que
ça peut être des Français ça peut être
des Anglais des Américains et cetera qui
viennent si ça pose un problème que ça
soit des Israéliens parce que ça fait un
conflit direct avec la population pas de
souci du moment qu'on a la compétence
c'est un problème de compétence la
compétence elle doit être policière au
niveau luner pour éviter qu'on
recommence qu'est-ce qui se passe en St
Jordanie en ce moment là bah il y a
toujours la S Jordanie elle est elle s
Jordanie ou Judée Samarie alors si on
est pro israélien on va dire judé sa
Marie et si on est colon on va dire
Judée sa mari si on est neutre on peut
appeler ça si Jordanie on peut appeler
ça si on est droit
international c'est voilà une zone
pauvre sans ressources naturelles
particulières difficile à
vivre qui coûterait une fortune à
développer donc pour faire un État
palestinien comment on va financer ça là
et qui sera
enclavé parce que la Jordanie
elle a eu son compte hein elle en veut
pas donc
euh pourquoi les pays limitrophes dit
arabe n'accueillent pas les réfugié
alors l'Égypte a accueilli 150000
personnes qui ont payé chacune par
personne entre 6 et 8000 dollars pour
pouvoir passer la
frontière donc une femme avec deux
enfants p 3 fois 6000 d'accord c'est pas
il y a pas de cadeau et ça a été payé
directement au service de renseignement
is
égyptien mais bon l'Égypte c'est un cas
particulier aussi on a à la tête de
l'Égypte un dictateur qui s'appelle
al qui est bien vu par l'Occident parce
qu'il achète nos rafales et qu'il achète
nos armes et cetera mais qui détourne
des fonds mais pire que Mbarak avant
preuv de ça oui ou ouais et euh et c'est
terrible c'est terrible et en plus le
problème de l'Égypte c'est que
euh il pratique l'arrestation euh mais
brutale quotidienne pour un oui pour un
non enfin c'est tout ce qu'il faut pas
faire pour empêcher le terrorisme de
progresser là je comprends que
évidemment ils ont peur des Frères
musulmans mais les Frères musulmans on
leur met une population dans les mains
parce que euh parce qu'elle est arrêtée
elle est torturée parce que et parce que
le il y a un klept qui est en train de
détourner tous les fonds avec la
bénédiction de l'Occident donc c'est du
pain béni il faut comprendre la
souffrance de ces populations
là on voit on voit avec la Syrie
l'espoir qu'il y a au sein de la
population bon on pourrait en discuter
pendant des heures passons un peu à
l'Iran oui alors qu'est-ce que tu peux
nous dire de l'Iran est-ce que c'est un
pays c'est bien pour
voyager est-ce que c'est un pays qui
respecte tout un tas de choses les
droits de l'homme les droits des femmes
le droit des espions
occidentaux est-ce qu'il y a autre chose
que des pistaches en Iran et des des
Peugeot 504 alors oui oui et pourquoi
souvent demande mais pourquoi vous
attaquez pas l'Iran vous les les agents
et tout ça pourquoi pourquoi la CIA avec
tous les moyens qu'elle a pourquoi
pourquoi on bombarde pas l'Iran d'accord
parce que on avait pas l'espace aérien
syrien ça pose pas de problème l'Iran 88
millions de personnes
16 ethnies
différentes prenons les cachekailles
c'est pas une marque de voiture les
cachekailles on les trouve du côté de
chira cétait un peuple nomade qui s'est
cédentarisé les cachk ils ont essayé
d'avoir leur indépendance dans les
années 80 ça s mal
terminé les Kurdes veulent aussi leur
indépendance et leur attachement avec
sous la sous la sous la férule des
barzaniies d'accord il y a les balouches
les balouches veulent leur indépendance
il y a les azérriis les azérriis dont le
territoire est revendiqué par
l'Azerbaïdjan au qui on auquel on on va
donner des armes notamment israël va
donner des armes à Bakou
et ils ont une vue sur la population
mais plein tarif iranienne azée qui fait
à peu près 20 % c'est pas rien et donc
comme ça il y a 16 ethnies différentes
et quand on les rencontre et moi je l'ai
fait qu'on parle avec ces gens-là qui
veulent leur indépendance les leaders
attends je t'arrête tu l'as fait tu es
pas parti sur tes deniers tu étais en
vacances tu allais repérer ton ta petite
retraite pour te faire ton petit terrain
dans la montagne il y en a un il y en a
un qui m'a fait le plaisir de venir à
Genève et donc les discussions ont eu li
à Genève là-dessus c'est extraordinaire
Genève pour ça d'ailleurs ou ou on fait
toujours aussi bien du renseignement au
cul des hôtels à genè bien sûr bien sûr
c'est fait pour ça c'est il y a toujours
des mecs qui sont des ininguis habillés
en cuir avec des pommes dans la bche
non les banquiers sont
prochable
et et donc et mais il y en a qui aussi
qui qui sont présents sur les réseaux
sociaux mais mais et donc il peuvent
être interrogés éventuellement
euh jamais croisé de libien à Genève si
tu sais comment tu les reconnais
a la même marque de chaussur que toi
c'est bien B sans doute parce qu'on va
dans des endroits un peu particuliers
tout croté voilà mais difficile de
déconcentrer non ouais c'est difficile
de me
déconcentrer on reprend ses ethnies qui
veulent leur
indépendance qui veulent des armes qui
veulent de l'argent pour devenir
indépendant et une fois qu'ils seront
indépendant je leur dis mais voilà
est-ce que vous voulez un modèle comme
la Confédération suisse un modèle un peu
cantonnal on pourrait faire ça des
cantons et cetera avec un pouvoir
central non non c'est je je tu comprends
pas c'est je je prends le territoire là
je deviens président c'est à moi c'est
c'est moi le patron je suis le chef de
tribu voilà donc il y a pas
d'élection on renverse le pouvoir
central on fera un bain de sang
oui oui donc ce qu'on propose en fait
comme alternatif au Mola ça va être un
bain de sang généralisé avec un Iran qui
s'éclate la conséquence sur 88 millions
de personnes c'est une vague migratoire
comme on en aura jamais
vu et la seule porte de sortie c'est la
Turquie c'est l'Europe il a a beaucoup
d'Iraniens en Europe d'ailleurs oui il y
a beaucoup d'Iraniens et je les salue
ceux de la diaspora ils sont très
courageux faut l'Iran c'est 912 km de
frontière avec
l'Afghanistan donc quand on veut
déstabiliser un pays il faut regarder un
peu les voisins le Pakistan aussi hein
pas un voisin très facile hein
l'Azerbaïdjan on en a parlé il y a
l'Arménie bon qui est pas très stable
aussi donc vers où vers où on va avoir
cette population qui va fuir parce
qu'elle va fuir les combats la Turquie
l'Europe et là 88 millions de
d'habitants c'est autre chose que la
Syrie je veux dire la Syrie ça a été une
vague énorme qui a surpris Angela merken
qui s'est retrouvé àer voir les intégrés
et cetera on connait l' surprendre
d'ailleurs là c'était une
vacel tu connais tu connais le petit
dicton à force de ne jamais rien
anticiper on finit toujours par se faire
surprendre oui ça c'est sûr et mais là
justement on veut pas se faire
surprendre et donc pourquoi il y a
cette angoisse et et cette réflexion
vis-à-vis de l'Iran c'est c'est l'Iran
c'est un peuple qui est proche de nous
intellectuellement où les universités
sont bonnes les il faut voir le niveau
intellectuel des cadres iraniens même du
renseignement de la vevax c'est des gens
brillants c'est pas des imbécile hein
l'Iran a un partenariat aussi avec la
Russie qui est récent un partenariat sur
la défense qui est récent donc si l'Iran
veut avoir la bombe nucléaire ils
peuvent l'avoir de la Russie on parle de
qui te dit qu'ils l'ont pas déjà alors
voilà on parle de bombes tactique donc
de de petite taille par rapport aux
bombes stratégiques mais donc des bombes
de petite taille qui feraient 50000
morts j'entends bon c'est déjà beaucoup
euh suffisamment pour empoisonner le
plateau du Golan ah bah oui enfin oui le
problème de ça c'est pas d'avoir la
bombe c'est d'avoir le véhicule qui
permet de la transporter ils l'ont
d'ailleurs non alors ils ont des
missiles hypersoniques qui sont de la
technologie propre à l'Iran d'accord le
problème des missiles
hypersoniques c'est que ça va tellement
vite qu'il y a un échauffement qui est
hyper important qui est très important
et l'échauffement très important ça ça
crée des des des problèmes au niveau du
guidage donc la précision de ces
missiles là est pas encore au point bah
ils ont prouvé le contraire bah non là
là là si tu veux faire un objectif à
50000 morts la précision 200 m tu en a
un peu rien à faire là ils ont les les
les les mesures de rétorsion que l'Iran
a donné sur Israël euh ils ont tapé pro
ils ont alors d'abord ils ont quand on
peut remercier d'ailleurs les les
pilotes français qui ont décollé de la
base jordanienne on a une base en
Jordanie il y a des pilotes de rafales
qui ont décollé à un moment pour
arrêtter des missiles qui était envoyés
par l'Iran ils faont pas arrêé beaucoup
non si si non non il faut pas ils ont eu
c'était difficile c'était une mission
particulière comme on en fait pas
beaucoup dans une vie d'homme et et pour
ça on peut quand même dire bravo et et
bravo à ses pilotes et ça montre quand
même que la l'armée de l'air française
elle tient la route euh et euh bravo
aussi parce que non non non je je suis
pas condescendant vis-à-vis d'eux mais
il faut bien se rendre compte que l'Iran
me it
Jérusalem et le vieux Jérusalem c'est
tout
petit mais c'est le berceau des
religions de trois religions c'est un
symbole ça ça appartient au patrimoine
de l'humanité Jérusalem ça appartient à
personne
d'autre un exemple donc reviens sur le
vecteur nucléaire ouais le vecteur
nucléaire donc mettre mettre une petite
bombe atomique sur un missile
hypersonique c'est prendre le risque que
le missile euh il arrivera parce qu'il
est hyper sonique et que c'est difficile
à intercepter mais il arrive peut-être
pas au bon
endroit pas terrible à partir du moment
où il commence à être lancé la Rost elle
est immédiate et thérant n'existe
plus donc le choix du Mola qui va dire
bah moi je vais quand même envoyer ma
petite bombette nucléaire sur
Israël il fait le choix de détruire
tesant et il fait le choix de détruire
l'Europe en même temps non mais il
détruit tesant c'est sûr la la vague
migratoire dont tu me parles ça ah oui
après après après ouiis après il y a une
vague migratoire l'Iran éclate
voilà donc je pense pas qu'ils aillent
faire ça je pense que le chantage au
nucléaire il est aussi monté en épingle
du côté israélien pour qu'on s'attaque à
l'Iran et et récemment il y a eu une
vidéo de Jeffrey sax qui est un
professeur américain qui s'en est pris à
netanahou il a dit mais ce ce il a été
très dur avec lui il a pas dit cette
racaille mais cette personne là il a été
très fort très insultant euh nous a nous
a voulu qu'on aille faire la guerre en
Irak a voulu qu'on aille faire la guerre
en Syrie et cetera et maintenant il
voudrait qu'on aille faire la guerre en
Iran voilà et et Trump a retweeté cette
vidéo donc il a bien il a il a il est
d'accord avec ce que dit le professeur
Jeffrey sax et c'est un camoufl reter ça
veut pas direêtre d'accord enfin il est
il a il a retruité favorablement et
c'était un camouflé pour pour netanyiao
moi je pense tout de suite que Trump va
lâcher netanyiaou tout de suite dès que
son élection parce que c'est déjà un
loser parce que il a déclenché une
guerre sans avoir de stratégie et on l'a
toujours enfin tout le monde lui a dit
mais ok on fait mais quelle est la
stratégie alors qu'au départ il aurait
pu lâcher des prisonniers et re et avoir
les otages ça l'aurait pas empêché
d'aller envahir la bande de gaz à
derrière non même pas on peut se poser
la question si les otages israéliens
avaient été des orthodoxes est-ce qu'on
aurait eu le même traitement là on a des
kibouzim on a des laïques on a des les
filles en miniupes et cetera qui qui
faisaient la fête euh en plein air bon
euh la question se pose je n'ai pas la
réponse je pose la question on a le
droit de la
poser les procès en en perspective de
netaniaou c'est pour quel chef
d'inculpation alors il a déjà un procès
en cours alors qu'il est premier
ministre encore euh pour
corruption mais on va dire c'est commun
c'est commun maintenant dans les pays
occidentaux quand il y a ouais mais
enfin il il y a une procureur général
qui s'appelle Gali barav Miara qui est
une femme
extraordinaire de
courage toute sa famille a servi le pays
et brillamment et elle elle veut garder
des institutions indépendant elle veut
qu'il y ait une enquête sur comment on
est arrivé au 7 octobre
quand il y a
eu le 11 novemb le 11 septembre aux
États-Unis les tours jumelles
s'effondent et cetera du dans la minute
même toutes les agences de renseignement
se sont mis à travailler sur le 11
septembre les C été financé l'enquête
préliminaire sur le 11 septembre 600000
dollars beaucoup plus parce qu'en fait
c'était sur des budgets internes ouais
au début mais
bon et et ils ont mis le temps pour
avoir Ben Laden on aurait pu mettre le
temps pour avoir les les igent du Hamas
hein
euh le fait est que là ça fait
maintenant presque fait 15 mois que ça
dure euh aucune enquête on a le droit de
faire aucune enquête netanahou bloque
toutes les enquêtes moi j'étais avec un
procureur à tel av c'est pas netaniaahou
tout seul avec ses petits
bras c'est netanahou qui a la main mise
sur le pouvoir judiciaire avec l'extrême
droite et qui bloque l'enquête il y a
pas d'enquête
officiel d'état sur les événements du 7
octobre il y a les familles qui ont fait
une enquête privée bon ça pas la même
c'est pas la même impact donc il faut
absolument qu' cette enquête là et donc
tant qu'elle a pas lieu bah il y a une
suspicion moi je veux bien que netanahou
et droit à la présomption d'innocence et
cetera que le financement de la bande de
Gaza ça soit fait par le l'opération
voilà une illumination ou des erreurs ok
mais il y a eu des qu'on fasse une
enquête une en
quête revenons à
l'Iran donc l'Iran la
problématique moi j'entends bien la
diaspora iranienne demander des
changements qu'on fasse tomber les molas
et cetera mais on ne peut faire tomber
les mollas que si à la place on a une
autorité qui tient le pays or la seule
autorité qui tient le pays c'est les
gardien de la Révolution et il y avait
une
autorité qui a une
sur l'ensemble de qui avait une AA sur
l'ensemble de l'Iran parce que son passé
parce que son son enfance et cetera
c'était le le général cassem
soléani et et j'en parle c'est ça fait
partie du début du livre Raven le pacte
du catar le roman je parle de sa mort et
des circonstances de sa mort cet
homme-là quand il a commencé sa vie il
faisait des briques he c'tait un enfant
qui faisait des briques et il est arrivé
général et le général iranien et euh euh
et il était hyper
doué si tu avais une question à poser à
l'ambassadeur d'Iran tu lui poserit quoi
[Musique]
euh est-ce
que vous êtes prêt au
dialogue avec l'Occident sans les molas
tu penses qu'il va répondre
quoi je pense qu'il se pose la question
eux-même il a il y a des dissensions en
ce moment très importante au sein des
Gardiens de la révolution parce qu'ils
ent ils ont perdu beaucoup hein ils ont
perdu la Syrie qui était
énorme ils en ont marre de perdre et ils
ont et dans certains moi je je pense
qu'ils ont un peu d'animosité vis-à-vis
des des
Molas et les il se trouve que les
ambassadeurs sont des membres de la vvac
c'est des gens brillants et on peut leur
poser moi je crois que la solution avec
l'Iran c'est le dialogue et c'est
justement tendre la main aller là-bas
aller à théran on n'oublie pas les
otages qu'on a là-bas il y a trois
otages français qu'on a là-bas et il
faut les encourager une chose qu'on peut
faire et nous nous ici là tous on peut
faire he c'est écouter la chanson
Barillé la chanson Barillé c'est
magnifique c'est la mélodie est
magnifique les paroles sont sublime euh
cette chanson-là si elle fait un
milliard de vues
la vidéo l'écoute ça aura beaucoup plus
de poids qu'aller balancer une bombe sur
tes tu parles de la vidéo avec le piano
oui barailler donc ça veut dire pour en
farsie et c'est une chanson émouvante le
le l'auteur compositeur qui l'a qui l'a
qui l' faite c'est pris 3 ans de prison
il y est
encore c'est vraiment magnifique il faut
l'écoutter ça s'écrit B a R a y
e et il chante en en Fars c'est normal
mal il y a des traductions en anglais
vous allez voir c'est de la poésie c'est
c'est magnifique he et la mélodie est
est vraiment poignante euh mais ça passe
pas sur les radios françaises aucune
voilà donc on va on va nous dire oui
mais les droits de l'homme les machin et
on fait rien on fait
rien donc c'est notre job à nous voilà
un média comme sinkerview et ben je fais
de la publicité pour barailler ça me
gêne pas et ben écoutez barayer faites
en sorte que le monde entier écoute
barayer et ça ira mieux en Iran
t'inquiète pas nous on va s'occuper du
dialogue voilà revenons à un autre pays
tu veux qu'on se fasse quel côté du
monde le
Groenland est-ce que tu vois en ce
moment une guerre des ressources se
profiler d'une façon très agressive et
avec l'arrivée de Donald Trump et sa
capacité à parler franc alors elle a
toujours existé la guerre des ressources
hein on a fait les c'est pour ça qu'on
s'est fait les guerres africain là là on
est coincé là mais mais le problème du
Groenland aussi bien que ses remarques
sur le Panama et et le Canada can voilà
si on laisse Trump mettre la main sur le
Groenland par disons un dialogue forcé
je parle même pas d'invasion militaire
mais disons on leur tort le bras et hop
il récupèrre le groinland qui va
empêcher la Chine de prendre
taiïwan qu'est-ce qu'on va trouver comme
argument tout de suite tout de suite et
après Taiwan l'Australie Taiwan c'est
tout
petit l'Australie Trump il dit moi j'ai
besoin de ressources pour naturel bah la
Chine a besoin de ressources naturelles
donc
l'Australie les sous-marins ça va five
voilà ça veut dire quoi five oui les
cinq les les services des différents
pays qui partagent les informations
entre elles donc les États-Unis la
Grande-Bretagne l'Australie et Cera
est-ce qu'en ce moment c'est pas une
guerre États-Unis Chine avec la Russie
et l'Europe comme
proxy la guerre États-Unis Chine elle
existe sous d'autres formes le problème
de la drogue euh par exemple et donc ça
je le décris dans le réseau euh les
Chinois donc produisent du des des
composants qui permettent de fabriquer
le fantanil les précurseurs ce qu'on
appelle les précurseurs il les envoie au
Mexique parce que sur la côteest
mexicaine il y a beaucoup de sociétés
chinoises qui permettent de réceptionner
ces trucsl ça va après dans les cartels
mexicains en échange de quoi cette
collaboration la les cartels mexicains
blanchissent l'argent via les banques
chinoises et la Banque de Chine bon
alors là-dedans il y a aussi un il y a
pas que les Services chinois il y a
aussi la 14K et différentes mafias
chinoises qui sont décrites dans le
livre
et et donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut y faire
la drogue c'est un problème d'état à
état donc nous on a une réglementation
absurde à ce niveau-là
mais c'est une réalité et et ça ils s'en
servent comme arme euh donc il y a il y
a cette guerre là entre la Chine et les
États-Unis il y a une guerre de rivalité
évidemment de de puissance puisque la
Chine investit beaucoup dans son armée
mais on reste très loin le budget
militaire américain on est sur 1000
milliards de dollars un trillion par an
euh la Chine on est bien en dessous on
est même pas la moé t argumentaire tient
pas la route mais ton argumentaire tient
pas la route un slip en Chine ça coûte 2
€ à faire un slip aux États-Unis tu en
pour 10 ça doit être la même chose pour
les missiles
c'est un problème de de qualité
technologique
mais
mais ça serait intéressant de voir si
Trump quand je te dis slip c'est pour
comparer avec des drones pas chers avec
des bobines des bobines de fibre optique
derrière les Dron les drones de DGI
qu'on a retrouvé en Ukraine c'était
exceptionnel CIT un drone jouet arrive à
être modifié ça c'est mais on savait
déjà ça pour revenir à notre monde la
menace nucléaire tu crois tu crois pas
c'est pour énerver les gens pour faire
peur aux gens la démonstration de elle
est inutilisable aujourd'hui attends le
le la petite démonstration du missile
russe noisette comment tu dis noisette
en russe
oui mais non les les missiles
hypersoniques sont impressionnants c'est
sans doute
laavenir à condition d'arriver à
résoudre les problèmes de les problèmes
de guidage et d'échauffement des des
missiles mais
euh on travaillera sur des technologies
d'interception ça déjà fait ses preuves
en partie en
Ukraine ça continue euh et et c'est sans
doute l'avenir mais en ce qui concerne
l'arme nucléaire en elle-même et son
usage c'est
impossible parce qu'aujourd'hui les
économies sont tellement imbriqués
l'Iran a pour partenaire commercial la
Chine qui investit sur les les le gaz et
le pétrole entre autres je veux dire
donc attaquer l'Iran avec le nucléaire
c'est attaquer la Chine où on
va tu tu penses que les prochains
risques qui vont se matérialiser sur
l'Europe c'est
quoi moi je crois pas et je parle avec
mesure à la menace russe de fond la
menace russe elle existe parce qu'il y a
Poutine Poutine quand il aura signé la p
en Ukraine et qu'on fera le bilan et que
c'est son son propre appareil va le
descendre en flamme on sera débarrassé
de Poutine je sais pas ce qui arrivera
derrière mais ça pourra nous débarrasser
de
Poutine tu penses que Poutine il est
tout seul il va être assez isolé quand
même
hein il y a les Russes veulent un SAR
ils ont la démocratie ils connaissent
pas ils ont toujours
eu le cœur qui battait pour unzar pour
l'homme virile la l'image forte et
cetera euh
Poutine il est PL tout
jeune il a détruit l'économie russe
comme personne l'a fait avant lui avec
la guerre en Ukraine et ses conséquences
euh c'est catastrophique son bilan avant
la guerre en Ukraine il avait construit
beaucoup à l'étranger il avait un réseau
d'information il arrivait à manipuler
tout ça maintenant il a tous les les les
projecteurs braqués sur lui il a détruit
son économie pour avoir quoi rien le
donbas miné
rien donc les Russes sont pas dupes et
il y a pas mal de gens qui voudront sa
place tu vois qui il est âgé tu vois qui
a sa place ouf alors là ça est-ce que
c'est pas qui est-ce qu'on voit
quelqu'un qui
sera plus souple vis-à-vis de l'Occident
moins
peureux moins craintif de ce que
représentait la l'OTAN comme menace
euh moins moins volontaire pour jouer au
tsard
dictateur vraisemblablement la personne
qui va arriver aura besoin de
reconstruire la Russie il aura besoin de
la lever des
sanctions aura besoin de refaire
fonctionner
Nordstream donc
euh les Russes là aussi les Russes on
partage ça avec les Iraniens c'est que
leurs service euh c'est des gens d'élite
c'est c'est des gens intelligents pas
des imbéciles tu as été en Russie non
j'ai pas eu ce plaisir mais tu connais
des des des agents russes j'en ai
fréquenté un enfin j'en fréquenté un
j'ai eu une discussion avec un colonel
qui était un col
alors il était d'origine arménienne il
était colonel du KGB
euh et il était député
euh et quand ce qui m'a sidéré c'est que
quand
on a eu cette discussion il parlait un
français qui était presque meilleur que
le mien c'est facile c'est facile
ouais
et je me suis dit mais comment vous avez
pu apprendre ça vous êtes venu en France
vous êtes venu dans quel
territoire j'ai jamais mis les pieds
dans un territoire
francophonefrique et il me dit me dit
Mar ça c'est l'école du KGB
chapeau et c'est vrai
que les les agents qu'ils ont formé qui
sont des Infiltrés qui ont fait la
d'ailleurs l'objet de série tu par de
the Americans oui bien sûr ouais bien
sûr c'est c'est c'est la réalité
maintenant il y a la réalité du côté
américain ils ont fait rentrer il y a
pas très longtemps d'ailleurs des Russes
des
Infiltrés qui était moins bien formé qui
était moins bien formé qui sont fait
avoir assez rapidement ouais ouais ouais
ouais ils avaient été ouais ils étaient
moins bien formés mais alors il faut
savoir que il y a un programme aux
États-Unis qui s'appelle signature
reduction qui permet à des agents d'être
entièrement pareil entièrement sous
couverture total vraiment de A à Z avec
défaut tout ce qu'on veut et et qui ça
en fait beaucoup de monde est-ce que
l'intelligence artificielle ça crée des
problèmes au milieu du renseignement ça
aide non pas ça aide à trier
l'information imagine devoir lire une
bibliothèque
nationale tous les
jours c'est pas possible pour un cerveau
humain c'est pas possible pour une
intelligence artificielle ça l'est et
donc de cette bibliothèque journalière
il faut tirer 10 pages qui vont au
président des États-Unis tous les jours
si tu avais à donner C conseils à
Emmanuel Macron tu donnerais
quoi démissionne non
change de conseiller alors
oui ça ça c'est sûr que il y a à faire
un peu à ce côté-là est-ce que tu as
suivi la la démission de son conseiller
diplomatique pas plus que ça mais mais
Emmanuel Macron il a plus rien à perdre
il lui reste un peu moins de 2 ans c'est
un bout Flica non mais il a plus rien à
perdre qui profite de ça pour se rendre
le plus utile possible tu penses pas
qu'il est un peu tenu par les
excusez-moi l'expression tenue par les
roustons par des puissances étrangères
mais pourquoi
mais non il a il a un rôle qui est je le
défends pas particulièrement mais mais
euh
euh c'est pas le président le plus
problématique qu'on ait eu je veux dire
on a eu déjà shirac et Sarkozi qui ont
été condamnés par la justice il faut
s'en souvenir il faut se'en souvenir que
Hollande on l'a dégagé comme jamais un
président s'est fait dégager euh après
un premier mandat et de la
médiocrité l'homme au scooter
oh là je veux dire dans la dans dans la
série des présidents qu'on a eu à partir
de Gaul et cetera celui peut-être qui
qui a le plus mon mon ma faveur ça
serait Pompidou mais Pompidou il est
mort assez rapidement shirac shirac
shirac était allez on va pas dire le mot
crapule euh mais
Chirac tu l'as dit quand même oui euh et
et ça me fait rebondir sur l'affaire
Boulin euh parce que c'est c'est c'est
les archives
euh si on avait eu une justice
efficiente au moment de l'affire boulin
euh on aurait vu que c'était les agents
duusdec sous les ordres de Pasqua qui
avaient fait ce tru- il voulent le
chahuter bon il voulait sourcé oui il
voulait l'intimider oui parce ça c'est
celui qui fait euh ce qui est tombé la
tête dans le saut la tête dans le lac
euh ver
vers les rigidités cadavérique n'était
pas dans le bon sens c'est ça voilà
voilà et puis il avait les yeux comme ça
pour un gars qui sucide tombé et et donc
en fait ils lui ont tapé dessus il a
fait un malaise il en est mort ministre
si il était ministre ministre en
exercice he et et il a pas un service de
protection aux personnes et ben non ça
donc il va voir focard le patron de la
francearique euh il se fait taper dessus
il en meurt et cetera et derrière on
attend maintenant l'affaire Boulin
elle est elle est jugée maintenant
euh c'est déclassifié depuis peu enfin
bon tout ça est ça a traîné pendant des
années on attend que pasquis soit mort
et shirac soit mort et cetera pour
donner la vérité bon on aurait eu la
vérité B Shirak aurait jamais été
Président ce qu' voulait dénoncer
c'était le financement par la
France-Afrique du
RPR aujourd'hui on a le procès libyen
avec l'affaire Sarkozi que je vais pas
commenter parce que l'affaire est en
cours euh donc il a le droit à la
présempption d'innocence euh mais ça
choque et ben à l'époque c'était le
Gabon c'était le Cameroun Paul ba enfin
les qui finançaient le RPR et voilà et
on trouvait ça normal de de que les prix
que des présidents François soient
financés sur les caisses de pays
africains comment on fait pour juguler
les ingérances étrangèes
euh on fait en ayant un service de
contre-espionnage important euh on fait
en faisant en sorte que tout ce qui se
passe à l'Élysée soit enregistré
documenté euh mais ça au Parlement
c'est c'est difficile au Parlement le
problème du Parlement c'est qu'il est
tellement plétorique he on a un
parlement de mémoire on doit avoir 577
députés 355 sénateurs aux États-Unis il
y a 100 sénateurs beaucoup moins de de
de congressman d'une manière générale on
en a pour 1 milliard de d'euros de
budget de la Chambre des députés et du
Sénat par
an la moitié ne sert la moitié suffirait
serait beaucoup plus efficace un exemple
un député a le droit de poser des
question au
gouvernement le texte dit la loi dit
voilà le le ministre qui reçoit la
question c'est une question écrite bien
structurée avec un format c'est très
réglementé le ministre a 3 mois pour
répondre et il répondent pas
pourquoi parce que quand il y a 30000
questions par an on peut plus répondre
et donc on dit bah voyez comment
voulez-vous que je réponde puisque j'ai
des milliers de questions donc ça n'a
plus de valeur bah oui évidemment il y a
des milliers de questions mais il y a
tous les voilà comment on fait pour
éviter de de des inérences extérieur le
député aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il veut
c'est savoir ce qu'il va tweeter dans la
journée est vilains de dire ça ils sont
pas tous comme ça
tu en connais beaucoup des députés j'en
ai connu ouais ouais 90 il y en a mais
il y en a qui sont de non mais il y en a
et de tout Bordin quand il y a eu par
exemple la la commission parlementaire
pour l'indépendance de la justice qui
était dir le président c'était Hugo
bernaliss bernacili donc qui est
LFI
euh j'étais en contact avec lui pour
voir un peu moi j'étais attaché à ça
l'indépendance de la justice c'est quand
même quelque chose d'important donc euh
et ben il a fait sa commission et puis
ça s'est terminé avec rien en fait une
commission parlementaire on enterre un
sujet au lieu de l'amener en haut on
peut c'est une juridiction donc
normalement quand on témoigne devant une
juridiction on doit être on est tenu de
dire la vérité sinon c'est condamnable
mais il y a jamais de poursuite euh
Bernard casenu bon il y a jamais de
poursuite non pas Bernard casenu comment
il s'appelle benénala
non je reviens à ma question comment on
fait pour juguler les ingérences
étrangères il faut un un bon service de
surveillance de contreespionnage mais
bon on on a vu qu'avec le les r et on
l'a vu pendant toute la guerre froide
c'était difficile il faut avoir des
personnes qui servent l'état avant de se
servir eux-mêmes
aussi c'est ça le
problème quand on a des politiciens qui
sont pront à la
corruption prenons la période Sarkozy
on a Claude guant condamné
arrête ça a été
condamné Rachid est-ce que ça a été
condamnéini il est jugé alors il a la
présomption comme Rach la présempption
l'innocence aussi est mise en
examen on avait quand
même florilè balcie làdedans on avait
jury les ingérences étrangères elles
sont où làdedans
le
Qatar et partout est-ce que pour toi qui
fait le plus d'ingérence chez
nous alors le plus dangereux encore
aujourd'hui malgré le fait qu'on
combat le Qatar parce que les moyens
importants après l'ingérence est
différente quand c'est par l'ingérence
russe au travers des réseaux sociaux et
tout ça c'est emmerdant c'est c'est
vraiment une plie c'est de la
désinformation
ça ça préoccupe beaucoup mais après
Poutine je crois pas que ça perdure mon
sentiment c'est je peut-être optimistme
mais un peu d'optimisme un peu ça va
nous aider d'A qui fait sur notre
territoire les chinois mais les Chinois
c'est de la technologie la Chine n pas
pour but de de bouffer l'Europe ou
d'avoir l'influence sur les les par
contre la Chine elle veut de la
technologie mais mais mais il est où ton
angle mort là
c'est-à-dire que pour toi c'est l'axe du
mal qui vient faire de l'ingérence
étrangère chez nous bah nous on n pas
les moyens d'en faire beaucoup est-ce
qu'il y en a d'autres qui font alors
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres de nos alliés
qu'on considère la main sur le cœur
comme des amis de famille des gens tmoin
notre mariage ça n'existe plus et qui
ont des drapeaux avec des petites
étoiles dessus et des petites rayures
non notre ami américain
tu te rappelles ce que disait JAC verges
la France la France C [__] des
Américains ou est-ce que tu penses que
les États-Unis font deingérence en
France ils essayent ils essayent de
faire pression bah on voit Elon Musk qui
a des vues voilà mais mais Elon Musk
mais vous oubliez quelque chose de
fondamental tu du temps à le décrocher
voilà mais Elon Musk Elon Musk il faut
bien se rendre compte elon mus c'est un
autiste asperger et alors et alors il
voit pas le monde comme nous le voit
mieux que toi non il y a il est c'est ce
qu'on appelle un un ahpi c'est-à-dire
qu'il est asperger HP et le c'est pas
une maladie hein mais le monde le monde
de l'autisme le monde tel qu'il est vu
par et et voilà c'est l'opposé des
neurotypiques et donc le il a une grosse
difficulté à communiquer avec des tiers
il a gros communiqué avec sa propre
famille il a une grosse difficulté à
à comprendre que ces les messages qu'il
envoie peuvent choquer les gens parce
que pour lui dans son esprit ça tourne
bon
euh donc est-ce qu'il est dangereux bah
il est dangereux parce qu'il est riche
mais c'est aussi une richesse de papier
c'est des c'est des quand je dis
richesse de papier ça veut dire en
action c'est côté en bourse quand on
voit Tesla qui prend 60 % simplement
parce que mus va se retrouver dans
l'administration Trump c'est ridicule
donc le jour où il se fait virer parce
que les les gars de l'administration
Trump en on marre d'avoir l'autiste
asperger comme qui part dans tous les
sens et ça ça va arriver ça ça ça va ça
va pas manquer on va voir si l'action
elle reste au même niveau maintenant il
est très riche on est 400 milliards peu
importe ça peut peut-être diviser par
deux mais mais le problème de musk c'est
ça musk il part il part dans tous les
sens et c'est normal dans son contexte
alors là en ce moment c'est comme ça
qu'il faut le gérer en ce moment il y a
une polémique sur Internet entre musk
qui soutient l'extrême droite à demande
euh les Américains qui financent x s
tank
d'influence dans les pays européens et
nous on fait quoi au milieu de tout ça
et ben on agit on agit avec difficulté
mais euh on agit on s'agite non non non
le monde du renseignement est là pour
essayer de rétablir l'équilibre mais on
enchie et c'est difficil euh parce que
moi il se trouve que j'ai un collègue
américain qui doit
sortir la preuve que l'AFD en Allemagne
est financé par les Russes avec les noms
et et les détails suite à une
infiltration qui a été faite d'accord
dans la FD ou chez les Russes la FD et
aussi les Russes via les néonazis qui la
filière néonazie bon
euh et donc pour sortir ce documentl
euh il y a eu différents journaux
allemands qui ont été approchés on a eu
un des avocats de la
FD qui c'est pas problématique parce que
les PRES sont là quoi l'article qui
raconte tout voilà j'espère que ça va
sortir la semaine prochaine un article
de qui c'est un document officiel je
peux pas trop en parler parce que tant
qu'il est pass non ça vaudra quand ça
sera publié et et j'espère bientôt la
semaine prochaine j'espère mais on a on
a eu beaucoup de difficultés là-dessus
et l'infiltration qui a été faite on va
l'appeler Gabriel l'agent euh elle est
elle est
Gabrielle
c'est au choix on ne donnera pas
d'information sur
l'agent
euh et donc c'est difficile le milieu
des noonazis est pas un milieu très
simple mais et il est surveillé il est
surveillé aussi à partir de Jérusalem
euh c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin d'avoir
des alliés làb làbas euh et
ouais c'est ça fait partie des dangers
identifiés en France h le milieu mais
c'est les néon américains ils appellent
ça comment la menace vanille c'est
ça euh est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaiteris aborder avec nous parce que
ça fait déjà 2h37 qu'on se tient cashoir
avec c'est l'heure de laapéro dans pas
longtemps et ben écoutez je pense qu'on
a pas mal couvert de sujets euh moi j'ai
toujours envie de souligner le fait que
la justice française doit être
indépendante et qu'on doit tout faire
pour l'aider et ça j'en démore pas euh
parce que c'est notre survie qui est qui
est qui est en jeu une société qui n'a
pas une justice indépendante et qui ne
combat pas la corruption n'existe pas en
tant que démocratie attends je t'arrête
une seconde voilà je t'arrête je trouve
que tu t'es un peu ramoli depuis la
dernière fois hein non regarde les
facteurs économiques de la France c'est
en train de se vrer balance commerciale
dégueulasse
l'éducation nationale qui morp l'armée
qui morp malgré le fait qu'ils aient
augmenté les budgets dans le le système
hospitalier qui se vautre tout se vautre
tout part en en sucette qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand un dans un pays tout ça qui
part en suc rappelle-toi l'effondrement
de l'acion
soviétique corruption mafia justice
inexistante et tu crois encore que la
justice française va s reprendre avec
les paramètres économiques qui qui qui
sont devant nous oui tu crois au Père
Noë parce que parce que la justice non
non non tu comprends pourquoi je fais la
provoque ou oui mais bien sûr mais mais
prenons des cas très concrets arrête de
croiser tes bras prenons des cas très
concrets les mains sous les fesses la
police financière et la justice
financière est très rentable bah très
rentable Stéphanie Gibo r Stéphanie jipo
on pas vu la couleur hein ça viendra
mais mais inallah je crois qu'elle va
avoir un dédommagement
elle va avoir elle sera
peut-être mais euh mais mais c'est très
rentable le fait est que
euh comment on pourrait financer deux
fois le parquet financier si on veut
doubler la taille du parquet financier
bah voilà on on arrête la bêtise qu'on
est en train de faire avec la répression
de la drogue qu'on a aujourd'hui qui
pourrit la vie d'une partie de la police
parce qu'ils sont en train de faire des
PV pour un gars qui a une boulette de
cheit alors que le cheit on en est à la
dizaine de tonnes je veux dire l'unité
de mesure du cheit c'est la dizaine de
tonnes on voit qu'il y a 1 million de
consommateurs de cocaïne 5 millions de
consommateurs de cannabis des saisis
records mais des prix qui n'augmentent
pas voilà mais bien sûr mais mais il
faut de l'argent pour acheter tout ça le
gramme de cocaïne 60 € le gramme de
cocaïne il faut être riche pour se payer
ça donc qu'on tape sur les consommateurs
ouis qu'on amende les consommateurs ok
mais sur le cannabis il y a 5 millions
de consommateurs
off la répression absurde qu'on a sur
sur le cannabis on ferait mieux de dire
au au on fait des commerces de cannabis
libre point barre comme tous les pays
qui nous entourent réglementer
réglementer pour qu'on ait des taxes
mais qu'on laisse les jeunes garder
gagner l'argent avec ça moi j'ai pas de
problème ils ont ils ont un business
model c'est plus c'est plus du petit
bricolage c'est du business model c'est
des entrepreneurs ils s'en foutent qu'on
a laissé est-ce qu'on a laissé le le
commerce de drog qui est un peu à volo
pour sédatterer une partie de la
beux mais non pas du tout mais mais
c'est vrai que le commerce notamment du
cannabis ça paye les factures de de
l'électricité du RO du Maroc surtout et
surtout et surtout de de de beaucoup de
foyers dans les bonlieux donc pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi ne pas légaliser ça
n'a aucun sens bien sûr les problèmes
médicaux et cetera mais les problèmes
médicaux on les a avec plein de choses
donc tu tu serais pour t'inspirer de la
réglementation
portugaise la plus libre possible à ce
niveau-là est-ce que tu as trois livres
à conseiller à notre communauté alors
comment il s'appelle d'ailleurs ton
dernier livre mon dernier livre ça
s'appelle Raven le pacte du Qatar c'est
sorti chez plomb et donc là je vous
emmène à la fois au Moyen-Orient et un
peu en
Ukraine et vous allez de bon hôtel non
ouais et vous allez découvrir aussi la
façon dont on traite un agent qui a été
lourdement touché
psychologiquement il y a plein de
détails euh d'anecdotes et cetera et
dans donc c'est comme dans le réseau euh
vous avez euh des faits réels qui sont
transformés pour que ça soit adapté en
roman mais je laisse des notes de
Backpage que vous lisez ou pas qui vous
permettent de vous de vous documenter
sur les faits réels et euh et Raven le
pacte du Qatar on a été vraiment
rattrapé par la réalité après de ce qui
s'est passé dans le Moyen-Orient
euh et le réseau donc le le premier
roman que j'ai sorti chez plomb voulait
faire en fait une série et une série
Netflix donc en fait les deux les deux
tomes c'est première série deè série
pour
l'écran
maintenant je cherche encore des
producteurs parce qu'il en faut c'est
quand même cher il faut il faut je
pensais demander à Nathalie Portman si
elle nous écoute parce qu'elle a monté
une société de production avec une
française qui a qui a brillée d'ailleurs
aux États-Unis son 06 non mais je sais
comment la joindre euh pourquoi parce
que donc les le couple de d'agents qui
travaillent euh bah il y a la femme est
israélienne c'est sa vraie histoire qui
est décrite dans le réseau euh ça m'
valeur d' eu quelques remarques de
collègu israélien qui m'ont demandé
pourquoi et comment j'ai pas changé son
nom et j'ai j'ai raconté son histoire
bah c'est pas choquant euh donc il y a
rien de choquant euh et
euh et donc les c'est intéressant parce
qu'on voit comment on se finance comment
on
travaille
comment tout ce monde là en fait
travaille en parallèle des
sociétés des sociétés civiles qui
existent et et on fait ça on fait ça
sans que vous vous en rendiez compte
euh est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
nous conseiller
alors si vous voulez savoir pourquoi
pourquoi vous payez cher l'électricité
et que ça va continuer et pourquoi il
est impératif que ça s'arrête vous lisez
l'homme qui en savait beaucoup trop
c'est sur les fraudes d'Areva c'est plus
financier c'est c'est c'est un peu
aussi mon passé
euh si vous voulez savoir ce qui s'est
passé les deux vous êtes intéressé par
des carrières militaires vous êtes
intéressé ou alors vous êtes un gamin de
banlieu ou vous êtes simplement
intéressé par le milieu djihadiste bah
je vous conseille jeu de guerre parce
que c'est les dessous de la guerre en en
Libye et en Syrie il y a plein de choses
plein d'anecdotes ça se lit facilement
et c'est publié quand même avec Florent
par par les éditions Masso et je
remercie Florent Masso parce que c'est
rare d'avoir des éditeurs qui ont du
courage et qui se disent ou là là c'est
c'est bouillant je vais m'en prendre
plein la gueule et ben lui fa moi je
veux trois bouquins que tu as pas écrit
alors trois bouquins que j'ai pas écrit
euh je te laisse réfléchir elle vaut
combien ta montre oh très peu combien
euh allez 50 c'est une Lipe oui c'est
bien allez tu as réfléchi je 3 secondes
de plus fr
euh tu as vu la série Z Americans
oui elle est moi je la trouve bonne
euh notamment vers la fin c'est bien
tenu jusqu'à la fin et ça montre le
sacrifice qu'il faut faire les trois
bouquins les trois bouquins moi je vous
conseillerai un livre peut-être de Anna
Arend sur le procès Eman parce que c'est
d'actualité il faut vous demander
l'intérêt de de du elle a elle a
documenté le procès à elle en a fait un
livre qui a un peu choqué à l'époque où
c'est sorti pourquoi parce qu'en fait
elle se rend compte que
aichman qui était un un artisan de la
solution
finale c'était d'abord quelqu'un qui
était en bas de l'échelle en Allemagne
qui était un monsieur person et qui a
trouvé son essort dans le parti et c'est
le parti qui l'a construit et alors
qu'il n'avait aucune compétence de rien
du tout
euh Hitler était peintre qu quand il a
commencé il avait fait la guerre il
était agent de renseignement hein bon
mais il était pas grand-chose non plus
et ça ce phénomène là c'est intéressant
de voir ça parce que c'est la médiocrité
qui devient une nuisance totale et c'est
un peu ce qu'on est en train de vivre il
y a des parallèles à faire avec la
société d'aujourd'hui donc
anarent et puis
euh oh ou les les titres j'en l al je
fais encore une une petite diversion
pour te laisser du temps pour R chir
sponsorisez-nous soutenez-nous sur tipi
on a besoin de vous pour tenir être
indépendant et faire des bons des bonnes
émissions des avoir de bons intervenants
ouais deuxè
bouquin je je honnêtement euh je te
laisse réfléchir encore bonne année
alors si lisez lisez des biographies
d'Einstein vous apprendrez beaucoup
lisez mais les titres je les ai pas mais
une biographie d'Einstein une biographie
aussi de
euh
Spinoza parce que c'est c'est un
philosophe intéressant euh Spinoza parce
que il était juif et il s'est fait
exclure de la communauté juive
maintenant il a quand même une rue à
téaviv euh et euh et lui il voit Dieu
partout dans la nature et cetera euh si
je vous parle aussi des bails ça vous
dit peut-être pas grand-chose les
baahils mais c'est une communauté
extrêmement intéressante en Iran qui est
extrêmement intéressante aussi au niveau
du renseignement qui est dans le livre
Raven le pacte du Qatar elle est décrite
là-dedans les ba c'est des gens qui sont
qui acceptent toutes les religions on
peut être bail et venir d'une autre
religion il y a pas de problème il
pensent qu'on peut s'élever au travers
de la science et Queen fait plus on
travaille plus on un peu comme les
protestants plus on se on a une chance
de de d'aller vers le haut et que la
science est est bénéfique pour
l'humanité et qu'il faut s'élever au
travers de la science et c'est des
pacifistes les bails sont aussi
pacifistes que peuventêtre les
bouddhistes est-ce que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes générations pas le même
que tu as donné la dernière fois sinon
je vais te taper dessus non la dernière
fois tu avais dit au jeunes Français de
se barrer je résume trivialement ouais
là tu vas nous dire quoi
battez-vous tout de suite ouais
battez-vous pour aller en haut et pour
qui et et et moi par pour le pays moi il
se trouve que que j'entraîne des des
jeunes euh en sport à la box taille bon
à la box taille bon euh c'est pas des
jeunes très favorisés euh ils viennent
de tous les milieux ils viennent de tout
il y a des d'origine différentes on va
dire mais c'est pas des jeunes favorisés
mais ça me fait plaisir en fait de les
entraîner ça me fait plaisir de les voir
réussir parce qu'ils s'accrochent et je
les mets jamais en situation d'échec
parce que j'ai j'ai trop plaisir à les
voir progresser et je me dis bah là euh
au moins c'est pas per s'il y a ça leur
donne une chance en fait de leur prouver
que s'il s'accrochent et que ils font
des efforts et qu'ils sont disciplinés
et c'est dur l'entraînement est dur ils
vont aller vers le haut et c'est ça le
message d'espoir si j'ai un message
d'espoir à donner aux jeunes je leurd
fort au combat on remercie toute la
communauté les 5000 personnes qui
étaient en direct avec nous pour te
suivre on leur souhaite une bonne année
une bonne année à la communauté marque
et changer merci merci
[Musique]